digital marketing stands out as an
exceptional career path primarily owing
to its remarkable demand across various
Industries the multitude of
specialization opportunities it presents
the Perpetual need for staying up toate
with current with evolving Digital
Trends the scope it offers for
unleashing one's creativity through
comping campaigns the advantage of
datadriven dis ision making through
precise result measurements the
flexibility of remote work options the
potential of entrepreneur Ventures the
ability to reach a global audience the
promise of competitive salaries and
enduring job security it offers
collectively rendering it a dynamic and
exceptionally rewarding field for
personal and professional growth in a
digitally interconnected world so if you
are looking to grab a successful career
in digital marketing simply learn has
got you covered with a wide range of
topn digital marketing courses these
courses make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner semrush and there's a huge list
on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these course find the link to the course
in the description box so without any
further delay over to to does digital
marketing is all about promoting
products and services using the internet
and digital channels it's an
everchanging field that helps businesses
reach their customers and achieve their
marketing goals in 2024 there are few
important Trends to keep in mind First
artificial intelligence and machine
learning are playing a big role these
Technologies helps businesses
personalize their marketing efforts and
provide better customer experiences
video content is also becoming more
popular platforms like YouTube and Tik
Tok are great for businesses to engage
with their audience and showcase their
products or Services social media is
still a big part of digital marketing
platforms like Facebook and Instagram
allow businesses to connect with their
customers and build brand awareness
influencer marketing is also on the rise
where businesses collaborate with
popular social media users to promote
their products digital marketing is not
just a tool for promotion it's a way to
build meaningful relationship ship with
customers and adapt to the changing
digital landscape so in this video on
digital marketing road map 2024 we will
learn about digital marketing and its
salary structure we will also understand
the step-by-step road map in which we
will be covering the learning path to
become a digital marketing professional
but before we begin let me ask you a
quick question so what does ROI stand
for in digital marketing option A is
return on investment option b is reach
of impressions option C is revenue on
investment and option D is rate of
interaction now you can pause this video
and answer in the comment section below
all right so let's start with the topic
which is digital marketing professional
salary so the salary of a digital
marketing professional can vary
depending on factors such as experience
location industry and the size of the
company in general digital marketing
professionals can earn a competitive
salary for an entry-level position or
those with less experience the average
salary can range from $40,000 to $60,000
per year as professionals gain more
experience and expertise in the field
their salaries can increase
significantly midlevel digital marketing
professional with few years of
experience can expect to earn between
$60,000 to $90,000 per year whereas
senior level digital marketing
professional with an extensive
experience and proven tax record of
success can earn salaries upwards to
$100,000 all right so this one was about
digital marketing and digital marketing
salary now let's move on and understand
the digital marketing road map for 2024
so here are the basic steps and learning
path if you're looking to become a
successful digital marketer first is
learn the essentials of digital
marketing digital marketing is a broad
term that encompasses various techniques
and methods used to promote websites or
products online it is not a single
discipline but rather a collection of
strategies that businesses can employ to
reach their target audience these
strategies include search engine
optimization social media marketing
content marketing email marketing and
more by utilizing these techniques
businesses can increase their online
visibility attract more website visitors
and ultimately Drive conversions and
sales digital marketing is essential in
today's digital age as it allows
businesses to effectively connect with
their audience and achieve their
marketing goals next is understanding
seo seo or search engine optimization is
a a crucial aspect of digital marketing
it involves optimizing a website to
improve its visibility and ranking on
search engine results pages to master
SEO one must focus on keyword research
and on page optimization techniques this
involves identifying relevant keywords
and incorporating them strategically
into the website content additionally
understanding link building and backlink
analysis is important for building
authority and credibility technical SEO
knowledge is also necessary including
optimizing website speed and ensuring
well structured site by mastering
YouTube SEO Google SEO local SEO Etc
businesses can enhance their online
presence and attract organic traffic
from search engines PPC advertising or
payperclick advertising a powerful
digital marketing strategy that allows
you to create an oversee campaigns on
platforms like Google ads and Bing ads
this skillful approach involves keyword
Bing where you choose the words or
phrases for which you your ads will
appear you must learn ad targeting
ensuring your ads reach the Right
audience Etc crafting compiling ad
copies is another essential aspect as it
entices potential customers to click
monitoring campaign performance is
crucial enabling you to tweak and
optimize for better results all right so
this was about PPC advertising coming to
the next one which is learn social media
marketing social media marketing is a
crucial aspect of promoting website
effectively depending on the nature of
the websites it is essential to explore
various social media networks such as
Twitter Pinterest or LinkedIn each
platform offers unique opportunities to
engage with different Target audiences
and expand brand visibility to succeed
in social media marketing one must
possesses the necessary skills to create
and compel content engage with users and
analyze data to optimize strategies so
this was about social media marketing
all right coming to the next one which
is conduct content marketing campaigns
learning how to conduct marketing
campaigns is a crucial skill for
aspiring digital marketers it involves
identifying target audience creating
diverse content strategies and
maintaining consistency in content
delivery monitoring key metrics like
website traffic and engagement traes is
a vital for success by mastering these
skills individuals can excel in the
dynamic field of digital marketing
adapting strategies based on the AUD a
behavior and Data Insights gaining
Proficiency in campaign management is a
fundamental step towards becoming a
successful digital marketer all right
now coming to the next step to become a
digital marketer which is knowledge of
email marketing email marketing is a
powerful strategy for businesses to
engage with their Audience by learning
how to build effective email marketing
campaigns you can create compelling
content that resonates with your
subscribers understanding email
Automation and segmentations allows you
to send targeted messages based on
customer preferences and behavior
utilizing email marketing platforms and
tools streamlines the process and helps
you track campaign performance all right
so this was about the knowledge of email
marketing now the next step for the
learning part to become a digital
marketer is to learn data analysis and
Reporting tools data analysis and
Reporting tools are essential for
digital marketers to make informed
decisions and optimize their campaigns
some popular tools include Google
analytics which provides detail insights
into website traffic and user behavior
and Google data Studio which allows
marketers to create visually appealing
reports and dashboards other tools like
SC rush and Moos help with keyword
research and competitor analysis these
tools enable marketers to track key
metrics identify Trends and measure the
success of their digital marketing
efforts ultimately leading to more
effective strategies and improved Roi so
this was about data analysis and
Reporting tools now now coming to the
next step which is be updated with the
latest trends so the digital marketing
industry is constantly evolving with
changes happening on a daily basis this
makes it an exciting and challenging
profession as experts must continuously
learn and adapt the dynamic nature of
digital marketing ensures that
professionals never get bored as there
are always new strategies Technologies
and Trends to explore staying updated is
crucial to success in this field as it
allows marketers to Leverage the latest
tools and techniques to reach their
target audience effectively so this was
about getting or being updated now
coming to the last step which is start
looking for opportunities to Kickstart a
career in digital marketing it's crucial
to build a strong portfolio and resume
start by showcasing your skills and
expertise in various digital marketing
areas such as social media management
content creation SEO and analytics
include any relevant projects campaigns
or or certifications you have completed
once your portfolio is ready begin
searching for jobs that align with your
interest and goals tailor your resume to
highlight your relevant experience and
skills and don't forget to network and
leverage online platforms to increase
your chances of Landing for your dream
job so this was about the road map that
you can follow if you're interested and
want to become a digital marketing
professional in 2024 digital marketing
has become an absolute GameChanger for
bus businesses all around the globe
turning it into a skill that everyone
wants to get their hands on it is like
having a superpow that allows you to
reach and engage with customers on a
whole new level if you have ever dreamed
of becoming a digital marketing expert
then you are in for a treat we will be
your digital marketing Mentor guiding
you through each step with Clarity and
enthusiasm from mastering the
fundamental marketing principles to
unlocking the secrets of advanced
strategies we have got you covered which
is learning marketing fundamentals so
learning marketing fundamentals is like
building the solid groundwork for your
digital marketing Empire it's all about
understanding the inner workings of
consumer Behavior unraveling the
mysteries of market research and
uncovering the secrets of effective
marketing strategies think of it as the
key that unlocks the door to success in
the digital realm to get started immerse
yourself in the world of marketing
through online courses insightful books
and Industry blocks these treasure
troughs of knowledge will equip you with
essential tools and insights needed to
navigate the everchanging landscape of
digital marketing once you have gained
the Basic Marketing knowledge then the
next thing you can do is create a web
page so imagine having your very own
Digital Playground a place where you can
Unleash Your creativity and showcase
your digital marketing skills to the
world that's exactly what creating a web
page is all about it is like having a
blank canvas where you can paint your
unique Brand Story and Captivate your
audience thanks to userfriendly
platforms like WordPress and vix
building a professional looking web page
has never been easier you don't need to
be a coding visit or a design Guru to
get started so once you have created a
web page you can start with learning
local SEO local SEO is vital for
businesses targeting a specific
geographic area optimizing websites for
local search results is key techniques
like optimizing Google my business
listings and obtaining online reviews
and targeting location specific keywords
are crucial by creating accurate and
comprehensive profiles on Google my
business businesses increase their
visibility positive reviews build trust
and credibility while location specific
keywords help businesses appear in
relevant local searches embracing local
SEO techniques ensures businesses
connect with the potential customers in
their area gaining a Competitive Edge
and driving grouth so learning local SEO
is also important the next step is SEO
on page off page to become a digital
marketing expert you must Master both
onpage and off-page SE techniques onpage
Su involves optimizing elements within
your website such as metatags headings
and content off-page SEO on the other
hand focuses on building high quality
backlinks and increased website
Authority through strategies like guest
blogging social media promotion and
influencer Outreach by understanding and
implementing these techniques
effectively you can boost your website's
visibility and rankings in search engine
results ultimately driving more organic
traffic and achieving digital marketing
success now the next step is one of the
most important step that is PPC
advertising So Paid media marketing like
PPC advertising is a GameChanger for
driving targeted traffic to websites
pick a platform like Google ads or
Facebook ads and become a master in it
learn the art of crafting compelling ad
campaigns conducting
uh keyword research and optimizing ad
performance by focusing on one paid
media platform you will gain the
expertise needed to maximize your
marketing efforts and Achieve
outstanding results so dive in and
master your chosen platform and watch
your website traffic s after this you
can go ahead and learn the analytical
tools so analyzing data is like having a
superpower in the world of digital
marketing it's like a secret source that
helps you understand what's working and
what's not working to become a digital
marketing expert you need to get cozy
with analytical tools like Google
analytics these tools are like Treasure
Chest filled with valuable insights
about your website traffic user behavior
and campaign performance to start by
learning how to set up tracking codes
which act as a digital breadcrumbs
guiding you through the vast online
landscape then dive into creating custom
reports that give you a personalized
view of your data but don't stop there
the real magic happens when you
interpret the data and use it to make
informed marketing decisions so learning
analytical tools is also important if we
want to become a digital marketing
expert so now next is learning marketing
stack so learning about the marketing
stack is like unlocking a treasure Trove
of tools and software that can
supercharge your digital marketing
efforts picture it as a collection of
powerful weapons in Your Arsenal you've
got an email marketing platform like
MailChimp which help you craft
captivating campaigns that land right in
your audience's inbox then there are
social media management tools and let's
not forget about marketing automation
software like hubsoft which takes care
of repetitive tasks by ging hands-on
experience with these tools you will
become master of efficiency streamlining
your marketing efforts and unleashing
your full potential after learning all
of these skills and tools you can go
ahead and learn Advanced topics first
programmatic advertising delve into
programmatic advertising which uses Ai
and automation to purchase and optimize
digital ads in real time understand how
it works and its application in various
marketing campaigns next is affiliate
marketing learn the Ines of affiliate
marketing where you promote other
Company products or services and earn a
commission discover how to find and
manage affiliate partnership
effectively all right now the third one
on the list is app market marketing so
in the age of mobile apps knowing how to
Market them is crucial explore
strategies for App Store optimization
inapp advertising and user acquisition
techniques so these three are the
advanced topics that you can Master if
you want to become a digital marketing
expert all right so becoming a digital
marketing expert requires continuous
learning practical experience and a
passion for staying updated with
industry Trends by following this
step-by-step guide you can can develop a
strong foundation in marketing Master
essential digital marketing techniques
and gain experience in advanced topics
welcome to this new video by simply
learn before we begin with top five
digital marketing certifications for
2024 let me take you through a quick
walk through the history of digital
marketing with the birth of personal
computers the concept of digital
marketing began to take shape early
marketers started sharing emails to
reach out to their customers around 1994
the first ever digital Banner went live
on the website
hotwire.com the best part about this
Banner was the banner was clickable ad
in late 1990 with the birth of search
engines marketers began to optimize
their websites to get higher rankings
thereby getting relevant traffic which
impacted positively on sales and the
rest becomes history today in the
digital world around 98% of Internet
users are influenced by social media
platforms because of this strong user
base social media has turned to one of
the best Marketplace if compared to
traditional marketing digital marketing
has high Roi thus making it more cost
effective with the evolution in
marketing techniques a lot of jobs are
emerging in the Market opening doors for
skilled digital marketers on an average
a skilled digital marketer earns up to 8
lakh rupees annually in India whereas in
us the salaries may go as high as
$16,000
per year so without any further delay
let's begin with top five digital
marketing
certifications the number one on the
list is post-graduate program in digital
marketing by Purdue this comprehensive
course is One-Stop solution for any
aspiring digital marketer it offers
master classes from per University
Howard publishing cases capston projects
35 Plus digital marketing tools and much
more skills are necessary for growth
with this program you will gain must
needed skills for digital marketing
including keyword research behavioral
marketing SEO sem social media marketing
content marketing and much more learn
tools like chat GPD Google Keyword
Planner Google ads YouTube analytics
Google Trends RFS and more gain
expertise in building and promoting your
website using live Interactive Learning
an year of experience is preferred for
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box at number
two on the list we have us Master
digital marketing course by I IM skills
this master program provides digital
marketing training with live online
interactive classroom covering all the
essentials of digital marketing gain
in-depth understanding of tools like
Facebook ads Facebook insights Google
analytics Keyword Planner Sam Rush MOS
Uber suggest and more check the complete
course details from the official website
of IM skills moving ahead to number
three we have digital marketing Masters
program this online Masters program in
digital marketing offers expertise in
SEO social media PPC conversion
optimization analytics content mobile
and email marketing with 12mon access to
the course you will gain industry ready
skills work on real projects and attend
Facebook expert sessions to tools
covered in this programs are the most
commonly used tools in the digital
marketing industry naming a few YouTube
analytics Google Keyword Planner Google
ads Bing ads hoot suit Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter and there is a huge list to go
with this master's program you get
hands-on experience with industry
projects and year of Prior experience is
preferred for this course get an amazing
discount by using the code ytb5 join the
course from the link in the description
box
at number four we have digital marketing
specialist by
LinkedIn it is taught by various
experienced professionals linkedin's
online course provides no pressure
environment for entry-level marketers
wishing to build the knowledge of
digital marketing this course has almost
20 hours of on demand videos broken down
into 11 modules this is an ideal course
for people with little or no experience
with digital marketing it provides
comprehensive overview of all all the
leading digital channels including
Google ads or bpc SEO email and social
media learner will also get a basic
introduction of Google analytics content
marketing Facebook and Instagram and
even learn the fundamentals of graphic
design using Adobe products each video
module includes a quiz to test how much
you have learned and you will receive a
certificate upon the completion of all
modules the number five on the list is
digital marketing courses by digital
Vidya digital Vidya is government of
India approved digital marketing
platform that provides various digital
marketing certifications in Google
AdWords Google analytics HubSpot and
more the course curriculum is designed
with six core modules making beginner to
learn SEO email marketing inbound
marketing search engine marketing search
engine optimization web analytics and
much more you can check the other
courses you can check the course details
on the official website of digital Vidya
now let's see what digital marketing is
in simple words digital marketing is the
promotion of a product or a brand
through one or more forms of electronic
media such as Internet mobile phones
Google search engine marketing Etc it's
a way to reach client on time and retain
them with interactive marketing using
digital Technologies also it is the most
accessible easy to use and contemporary
method of promotion which is also known
as online marketing so when we want to
go and promote our product or service
using a campaign we have different
options so there are different types of
digital marketing channels that we can
choose from and let's just go through
that list of digital marketing channels
and the first one is what I consider the
king of them all and that's SEO so SEO
stands for search engine optimization
there search engine marketing there's
email marketing affiliate marketing
social content mobile and then we can
get into subsets of each of these
digital marketing channels but really
we'll start with SEO because that's the
king and to me that's basically
increasing the quality and quantity of
relevant organic traffic on the search
engines including Google so depending on
where you're located in the US market
Google tends or has a large market share
so you want your pages on your website
to be found and clicked on organically
and so that means if somebody types in a
key word you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay and here's an example so you
type in online shopping well you can see
the first listing here is a paid search
ad and we're going to get to that in a
minute the second organically is Amazon
okay so online shopping you think maybe
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw at the previous example if you
want to be found for keyword you don't
have to worry about organic if you're
willing to pay for it you just bid on
that key keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well my
us.com is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above Amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happen to clicked on that listing then
my us.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to $100 it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day depends on quality score there a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however the benefit of sem is
visibility and getting traffic to your
website for keywords you're not found
for so that's why sem is such a popular
choice for a lot of companies okay let's
talk about digital marketing that's a
traditional type of digital marketing
channel it's been around a long time you
know we all send emails on a daily basis
and we probably all receive emails on a
daily basis just is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you could
send your emails to a segmented audience
okay so if you have emails from females
who are 35 years of age to 44 that live
in say the southern part the United
States you can segment that send them an
email and cater that email directly to
that audience and of course you can put
some nice call to action in there you
can design it really snazzy and you can
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out if you're
selling a product and the product's
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase product and if
you purchase it you're going to get 30%
off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
emo marketing okay we have a affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a Salesforce of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-
party affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you could see earn up to 12%
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
click clicked on that purchased for
example or joined you could pay out that
commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know I wouldn't say
it's fairly new I mean if I think about
it we're in
2019 and I remember talking about
Facebook back in 2006 so you're talking
about 13 14 15 years of social media
it's definitely evolved over the years
and but the concept Remains the Same it
involves creating different types of
cont content depending on the platform
okay so you could be on Pinterest or
Instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on Twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media can be effective
because people use social media I mean
Facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
content organically okay that's the
beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they all have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so was social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because there are a lot of
different social media platforms out
there it really depends on your product
or service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on Facebook
with Facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you can post an ad and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
so content marketing is really an
effective way of really Distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video
where could be an an infographic or it
could be an image okay there are lots of
ways to create content these days
especially in digital marketing and the
great thing about content marketing is
you're writing content for a targeted
audience so if you're trying to Target
an audience on say Instagram then you
know who your audience is and you know
what the type of content you're going to
post on there so it could be in the form
of a video or infographic or just a
graphic and so that's the beauty of
content marketing really putting
yourself out there um and depending on
the platform putting yourself out there
with various types of content so for
example we look at YouTube you could see
this video here about digital marketing
certified associate well hey you don't
need to always write the content you can
produce the content in the form of a
video and post it on YouTube this is a
form of cont content marketing so that's
content marketing and then let's talk
about mobile marketing so content
marketing again different types but if
we go now to mobile marketing you can
kind of segue from content to mobile
because the only difference here is with
mobile it's strictly on mobile phone
it's not desktop so mobile marketing is
really a strategy on its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your Target on
audience through a mobile device and
that includes tablets and how you could
do that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app and install and
so you can even compound that by running
a say Google ad as an example and
running your Google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bit adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to really promote your app
or your product or your service Via
mobile marketing digital marketing plays
an essential role role in most
businesses today this has led to an
increase in the demand for digital
marketing professionals because of this
many people are interested in learning
about digital marketing it is becoming
one of the essential skills that you can
have if you learn how to use it you can
make a difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I'm Tushar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we will discuss the top 10
reasons to learn digital marketing but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay
tuned so without any further delay let's
get
started easy to start a career a career
in digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training in
digital marketing as a lot of free and
paid resources are
available a technical and creative field
both Technical and creative skills are
necessary for digital marketing it has a
lot of sub field hence it requires a
unique skill set and knowledge of the
latest technology for example a social
media marketing professional should know
how to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical
Fields highly paid digital marketing is
one of the most popular and trending
Industries there is a v demand for
digital marketing professionals as a
result digital marketing roles are also
very well paid your expertise could help
you gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman Sach report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by
2025 which shows the extent of digital
marketing in India and the job demand
for digital marketing according to Glass
do a digital marketing manager earns
around 7 lakh in India and HEI can earn
roughly
$123,000 in the
US become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online also you can start your
own freelancing business where you can
offer various services to the clients
all aspiring entrepreneurs need need to
embrace digital marketing and even the
old ones need to adapt in order to
grow career growth there are a lot of
digital marketing professionals around
but very few are skilled the demand for
digital marketing skills will increase
in the near future due to digital
economies rapid growth many individuals
are starting their online businesses and
almost every new company starts with an
online presence hence it's a perfect
chance for individuals who are looking
to make a career in digital
marketing the next reason is
versatility digital marketing offers a
variety of career options and a lifetime
learning since there are so many aspects
to it for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for 2 years and now
you want to work in SEO in that case
there is relatively little training you
need so it won't be that difficult to
switch over if you want to enter into
some other domain your digital marketing
experience will always be valuable
therefore it is said that that digital
marketers can easily change
jobs the next major reason is more
number of jobs several new jobs were
created in the digital marketing field
after coid as most businesses came
online you will find many digital
marketing job opportunities on LinkedIn
every single day Grand View research
reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56 billion in 2021 and is expected to
grow at a compound annual growth rate
cagr of
19.1% from 2022 to
2030 the field of digital marketing is
was however digital marketing is also
used in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trustworthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain time and cost
effective in the long term digital
marketing will save you a lot of time
effort and money traditional marketing
is expensive and the cost keep Rising
there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of
efforts the next important reason is
recision proof job lending your dream
job job is a rarity for many in this job
market with the economy still struggling
businesses are cutting jobs left and
right so how you can make yourself
Recession Proof if you are creative and
willing to learn it can happen there are
many ways to make yourself more
desirable to businesses and get job
offers however one way is to become an
expert in digital marketing digital
marketing is the internet-based
marketing of product and services using
digital Technologies mainly on the
internet marketing is an inte part of
any business with the ever growing
number of Internet users it is expected
that more companies will use digital
marketing extensively in the
future so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of
specializations SEO content marketing
influencer marketing sem and many other
fall under digital marketing an
individual has a lot to explode and once
you explode you can pick a digital
marketing specific specialization
according to your interest additionally
there is a wide variety of skills that
you need to master under each of these
categories digital marketing is a
strategic method that utilizes digital
channels to promote products or Services
it involves activities like social media
marketing SEO content marketing and
email marketing to engage with a
specific online audience the objective
is to increase brand visibility attract
customers and generate leads and improve
conversions by leveraging digital
platforms and datadriven insights
businesses can optimize their marketing
strategies personalized communication
and measure campaign performance in
today's competitive online landscape
digital marketing provides a coste
effective and trackable approach to
connect with customers and drive
business growth these days digital
marketing is one of the most trending
jobs digital marketing jobs are trending
due to Growing online presence cost
Effectiveness targeted marketing
measurable results constant Innovation
and Global Reach This has increased the
amount of digital marketing
Professionals in the industry it is
predicted to have approximately 8 lakh
6,000 job openings in 2023 from apparel
industry to it fintech and Pharma
digital marketers are in huge demand the
salaries of digital marketer May differ
depending upon the skills location or
the company however on an average the
salary of digital marketing manager in
India is 6.4 lakhs per anom rupees
whereas in us it is
$122,000 perom so hey everyone if you
are looking to try your hands on in this
field then here we have a magic course
that will help you to gain excellence in
this domain and grab highest paying jobs
under digital marketing presenting you
so before we begin begin with the
digital marketing road map consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn so without any further Ado
let's begin with digital marketing road
map for 2023 in the dynamic world of
digital marketing a marketing road map
is a crucial for businesses to navigate
successfully towards the growth by
defining goals understanding target
audience and implementing effective
strategies companies can establish a
strong online presence and Achieve
marketing objectives so here are the
basic steps if you are looking to become
a successful digital marketer let's
begin with step number one establish a
solid foundation learn marketing
principles and strategies be good with
communication and writing skills develop
analytical skills analyze data to drive
insights understand consumer behavior
and market trends the next step we have
is to to gain expertise in SEO and PPC
campaign SEO or search engine
optimization Master keyword research and
onpage optimization techniques as this
is the base of any digital marketing
efforts understand link building and
backlink Analysis with this it is also
necessary to have good understanding of
technical SEO including website speed
optimization and site structure stay up
to date with search engine algorithm
changes next is payperclick advertising
or PPC learn to create and manage PPC
campaigns on the platforms like Google
ads and Bing ads develop skills in
keyword bidding and targeting and add
copyrighting keep an eye on the campaign
performance and optimize for better
results explore remarketing and display
advertising moving ahead we need to
understand how to Leverage The Power of
social media and marketing gain
Proficiency in major social social media
platforms like Facebook Instagram
Twitter and Linkedin understand social
media advertising and audience targeting
create engaging content and manage
social media communities analyze social
media metrics and utilize management
tools moving ahead content marketing and
email marketing are the powerful
techniques to gain more leads here
talking about content marketing develop
content creation skills like content
writing graphic design and video
production learn content distribution
strategies like guest blogging and
influencer Outreach use analytics and
measurement tools to evaluate content
marketing Effectiveness moving towards
email marketing learn to build effective
email marketing campaigns understand
email Automation and segmentation
utilize email marketing platforms and
tools comply with email marketing
regulations and best practices with all
the above practices
it is necessary to have knowledge of web
development acquire knowledge of HTML
CSS and JavaScript get detailed
understanding of content Management
systems or CMS like WordPress uiu design
and more data can provide valuable
Insight in the business growth gain
expertise in data analysis learn tools
like Google analytics and Google tag
manager analyze website traffic user
behavior and conversion rate experiment
with AB testing which will help you to
understand what works better for your
content utilize data to inform marketing
decisions and enhance campaign
performance last but not the least stay
updated stay updated with industry news
Trends and best practices attend
webinars conferences and workshops
engage with online communities and
participate in discussions get certified
in Google ads go Google analytics
HubSpot or Facebook blueprint well to
bring it to your notice the postgraduate
program and digital marketing covers all
the requirements as we discussed in this
video check the complete course details
from the course Link in the description
box greetings everyone this is Rob
Sanders from Simply learn happy New Year
and today we're going to talk about
digital marketing skills so digital
marketing allows business owners
regardless of the business nonprofit
for-profit large or small National local
International to really expand their
business allows them to personalize
their content they could save money and
most importantly they can measure the
results and so that's what we're going
to focus on today when we talk about
digital marketing skills focusing on
measuring those results so suppose
anybody wants to work in marketing or
grow a company or help grow an
individual's company or Ure to keep up
with the appropriate skills this is what
we're going to cover today so we're
going to cover a few channels and so
let's get right to it today we're going
to start off with search engine
optimization or SEO also known as
organic search so
SEO is an interesting channel uh it's
probably the premier channel for most
companies in fact HubSpot confirms that
50 7% of B2B marketers stated that SEO
generates more leads than any other
marketing initiative so it's really
important for not only just generating
traffic but it's also important for
generating leads and and generating more
business including e-commerce and so
what does SEO entail and what skills
should you acquire in order to manage
SEO as a marketing channel well if you
think about it SEO is really divvied up
into two pies one Pi is called on page
the other Pi is called off page and so
on page consist of things you can do to
the website to help you be found in
organic search so what are those things
well it could be anything from you know
page load speed to 4 four errors to S
maps and so the point here is is if
you're going to manage SEO and you know
that you got to make sure your website's
in tiptop shape or your client's
websites in good enough shape for Google
to recognize it as a legitimate site you
have to have some technical skills now
I'm not saying you have to be developer
but at the same time you have to know
what a 44 eror is you know have to know
where and how to generate a site map and
upload that site map you need to know
how to edit a robot's text file so those
are you know what I call soft technical
skills but they're all valid for SEO so
you have to have some technical
background staying in the on page Pi
okay you need to make sure you have not
only skills to write content but skills
to optimize content so you need to be
aware of all the different elements on a
page in order to optimize that page so
again that entails you know some
copywriting skills but more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copyrighting skills and enhance
them for SEO okay so making sure that
you're able to understand what it is
that you need to do to get a page
optimized so it can rank higher in the
search engine results so those are on
page
skills then you got the other piece of
the pie which is off-page so
understanding you know what it takes to
make sure your site is relevant so it's
understanding different metrics off page
metrics like page Authority domain
Authority external links internal links
and so generally most SEO managers have
a thirdparty SEO platform that they work
with like SCM rush or MZ so it's
understanding how to work with those
platforms to measure off-page results so
we always say that SEO as a digital
marketing channel is an 8 100b gorilla
well it is because you have on page and
off- page to worry about so the two of
those together you know is is quite a
task in order to rank and so what brings
SEO and all digital marketing channels
is understanding the metrics and
understanding what you're seeing in
order to measure results and improve
upon those results okay so that's really
the theme for all these digital
marketing channels we're going to talk
about today is it's really about okay
what metrics and how do I measure the
results and so when we look at SEO in
terms of measuring results on the onpage
side okay you're going to have to do
some keyword analysis you're going to
have to understand okay what volume is
you're going to understand how to get
the competition numbers okay and you're
going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics
then you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are
performing okay and then again the off
page you got different metrics like
domain Authority or page Authority you
have external links internal links you
have no follow and follows and and you a
lot these little metrics related to
off-page SEO so you're going to have to
understand what those metrics mean and
if you can to understand what those
metrics mean
and then more importantly act on those
metrics then that's what's going to help
you improve your results in terms of SEO
so again that's going to be the common
theme here so I'm just going to
highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand in
order to better manage SEO a channel
again on the on page side you need to
understand the technicalities involved
but for example page load what's a good
page load time it's a bad page L time
from a keyword perspective what's good
volume what's bad volume what's good
competition what's bad competition so if
you can understand the intricacies of
the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up
toate and have a complete knowledge of
the latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking okay
so that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads payperclick cost per click a lot of
acronyms a lot of ways to describe it at
the end of the day search and marketing
means that hey you as an Advertiser have
the ability and have the opportunity to
rank at the very top of the Google
search results now it's different than
SEO because you're actually paying for
the placement and so to be found at the
top of the search engine results as a
paid placement or sponsored ad means
that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're going to pay Google X amount okay
so unlike SC o sem is very fast
moving and so when we talk about fast
moving we mean that you're collecting a
lot of data very quickly so sticking
with the theme of what skills should I
have for search engine marketing well if
you're going to collect data then that
means you need to measure the results of
that data and so sticking with our theme
of measuring results you need to
understand first and foremost what all
the different metrics mean related to
centr engine marketing okay so I'm just
going to Rattle off if you will a few of
the metrics but the commonality here is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics so one of the the main metrics
involved with search engine marketing is
Impressions so impression is just
basically how many people have seen your
ad okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
seen your ad what's a lot of impressions
well it's objective okay so it could be
a thousand Impressions or 10,000
Impressions at the end of the day that's
how many people have seen your ad now
more
importantly you have another metric
called clicks clicks means how many
people actually saw your ad and then
clicked on your ad okay so if you have
100 people that have seen your ad and
one person who clicked on your ad then
you have a click through rate of
1% now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click the rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay to Quality score is simply a number
between one and 10 that's assigned to
each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you
have 200 or 300 or 500 or a th000
Impressions and very little clicks that
means your click through rate is going
to be low if your click through rate is
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low and in order to pay
less to Google you need to make sure
that your quality score is good so you
need to understand the factors involved
with quality score you need to
understand Impressions clicks click
theate because if you don't have a good
click theate
then how do you improve that so it's
about measuring the results and acting
upon the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you
got the conversion side of the house so
you need to be able to understand how to
get
conversions and how to maintain a high
conversion rate so for example if you
have 100 clicks and only one
conversion that is a 1% conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say $20 and you're only
selling a product that's say
$10 well then you got a problem and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low click the rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion or very low Impressions you
need to be able to understand how to
react to what you're seeing and what
data you're collecting that to me is the
primary skill bottom line with search
engine marketing and there are other
skill sets involved don't get me wrong I
mean it's nice to be able to write copy
because with search engine
marketing typically the ads have very
few characters involved so you need to
be able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing Copy being able to
understand your target
audience um those are all things
involved with managing search engine
marketing but really the key component
here is again measuring the results okay
let's switch over to a traditional
marketing channel email marketing you
know one of my favorites you know listen
we're all bombarded with
emails uh and you know what it it
becomes cumbersome at times I mean it's
easy to just disregard an email and so
to me the key here if you're going to do
email
marketing you need to have a certain set
of skill sets and so what that skill set
is is really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients you need to
hope that that email is relevant to that
audience okay so you need to be able to
really identify who it is we're sending
this email
to and a recent study done by
statista uh stated that 49% of consumers
really like to receive promotional
emails from their favorite Brands so if
you have a very strong brand then email
marketing is probably a good channel for
you if you don't have a strong brand or
nobody really knows about your brand or
your product for your business then
email marketing could be a little bit of
a steeper Hill to climb if you will but
really email marketing is it involves
emails that promote the brands products
and services and if you could Target the
Right audience or making sure you have
the Right audience then you got a good
chance of having successful email
marketing
campaigns but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copyrighting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighting saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email they're going to be able
to react to it so you know writing copy
with strong call to action or really
relevant copy that really talks to the
audience I mean those are all keys for
email marketing in my
opinion also one thing we didn't bring
up in search engine marketing but it
certainly holds true with search engine
marketing as well as email marketing and
that's AB testing and so AB testing is
simply taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs well you could certainly do
AV testing with email marketing that
means means taking a subject line that
has traditionally worked for you or is
relevant for that audience and then
creating a variant or different subject
line so if I'm going to send an email to
100 people I'm going to send
50 people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variant
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people to react to okay so if I see the
open rates higher for the variant
versus the traditional or the original
subject line then I know that this
subject line works and therefore I'm
going to apply this subject line moving
forward and then what am I going to do
I'm going to take it and test it against
another variant so you should always do
AB testing on subject lines so the
concept of AB testing should not be lost
on any digital Market okay whether that
be SEO search engine marketing or email
marketing okay so you should have an
understanding of AB testing and of
course going back to measuring results
with email you have a different set of
metrics we already mentioned open rates
so if you send out 100 emails how many
people open the email okay you want that
open rate to be as high as possible and
then when they open the email did people
click on that CTA or any of those links
in the email okay so you want a high
click the rate and then more importantly
when they click click on a link in the
email they're going to go to a landing
page you want that person to engage with
that landing page so what's the
engagement rate of the laning page from
the email okay so it's really important
that you have an understanding of all
the different metrics involved with
email marketing and again how to react
to that data so if you're getting a low
open rate could it be the subject line
isn't that good possibly that's why you
have have to do testing if you're
getting a low clicked rate on the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or the design or the call
to action or it's not compelling enough
for the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement and the landing
page if you have a low engagement rate a
low conversion rate you got to look at
that and figure out how to improve that
okay so you can apply AB Tes in the
landing pitch so there are always ways
to react to the data regardless of what
campaign regardless of what digital
marketing channel you're working in okay
so that's the commonality here one point
on email marketing is if you're going to
measure the results of the campaign
whether you're using you know vertical
response or MailChimp or you know some
other email marketing platform you want
to make sure you have what we call UTM
tracking and if you're using Google
analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign in Google
analytics so that's another skill set
you should have being able to apply you
know tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email okay because
if you don't it's going to be hard to
measure the results in Google analytics
so let's focus on one more marketing
channel here and that's social media so
we all know social media isn't going
anywhere it's becoming more and more
popular in fact you know an offshoot of
social media is really influencer
marketing uh you know if somebody an
influencer has millions of likes on say
Tik Tok or Instagram you might want to
engage with that influencer and help you
promote your brand or your product isn't
that really what social media is it's a
platform whether that be you know
Facebook or or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you you promote your
brand your product your services and
it's a chance for you to get to message
your user base your community
perspective clients people who don't
don't even know about your brand it's a
chance to build awareness so social
media holds a lot of different uh
strategies if you will in fact nearly
almost 4 billion of the world's
population uses social media let me see
There's 7 something billion people in
the world well that's a large percentage
the majority of the percentage of the
world uses a social media platform okay
in fact just like SEO where you need an
SEO platform there are plenty of social
media platforms there's later there's
Sprout social there's hoot there's
buffer in fact buffer confirmed that 73%
of marketers believe social media
marketing has been
somewhat effective or very effective for
their business and that's promising
because social media in my
opinion having been in this industry a
while it can be a very fickle Channel
meaning if you're trying to promote a
product or service on
Facebook and it's very very going to be
very hard to pull that person away who's
engaged with their Facebook feed not
only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and
convert okay based on what you have on
your website so it's challenging enough
just to get them away from the social
media platform let alone converting so
that's why when I say very fickle but
you know somewhat encouraging if buffer
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing can be effective
and it can be effective you just have to
have the right strategy so to me one of
the skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to
achieve when we set up a social media
platform or enact a social media
campaign okay and so that's really the
first thing it's really understanding
what platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content because just
like any other marketing channel you're
going to have
metric and social media is not shy on
the metric front Okay so you have
reach you have impression questions you
have engagement rate in fact every
social media channel has its own set of
specific metrics whether that be likes
followers
shares uh uh reviews Stars if you will
so it really depends on the social media
platform that you're using but at the
end of the day you need to be able to
measure the results if you're posting
let's just say on
Facebook and your whole job or strategy
is to entice engagement meaning get
people to share that particular post or
act on that post then you need to be
able to measure the engagement how many
people saw the post how many people
engage with the post okay and so just
like any other marketing channel you're
collecting data and you need to react to
that data but more
importantly it's about being able to you
know put a strategy together
first and then I would you know a skill
set I would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just named buffer or hoot sweet
or Sprout social they're all good in
their own right but they're all going to
have different features so to
me understanding what social media
platform works best for you you want to
choose a social media platform that you
know allows you to control what post you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on at the same time you want a
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the engagement that
you're getting from that
platform and you probably want a social
media platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform okay so you want a
listening tool if you will uh as part of
that social media platform so it's
understanding what platform you want to
use use when it comes to social media
marketing it's understanding what
strategy that that platform is going to
help you en Ena okay and then it it's
also that social media platform that's
going to help you understand the data so
you can react to the
data so those are all to me the skill
sets you need as a social media manager
and then an offshoot of social media is
paid social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
you're ad on LinkedIn and somebody
clicks on it you're going to pay for
that click you're going to pay LinkedIn
or you're going to pay Twitter you're
going to f pay Facebook so it's
understanding you know the skill sets
involved with paid social is
understanding what assets you can have
when advertising on these platforms you
know can you use video on LinkedIn or
Facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and you know how big do those
images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your
ads so having a full understanding of
the types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole another set of
metrics you know how many people saw
your ad how many people clicked on your
ad how many people engaged with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid
social so you have the opportunity on
paid social you have the opportunity on
social media
to to really get your message out there
it's really understanding what kind of
data you're collecting what are the
results of the ad or the post and how do
you react to that and that's really the
common theme with digital marketing
skills if you're not a big fan of
numbers you're not a big fan of excel if
you will or
spreadsheets if looking at a mountain of
data scares you well then you might want
to think otherwise when going into
digital marketing but if you want to
embrace the data then digital marketing
is really a great career because if you
can get the data and you know how to
react to the data then you can be
successful in any campaign you run so if
you are looking to grab a successful
career in digital marketing simply learn
has got you covered with the wide range
of topn digital marketing courses these
courses make you skilled in SE o content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sam rush and there's a huge list
on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these course find the link to the course
in the description box Rachel is a baker
who runs her own Bakery to expand her
business she decided to create an online
presence by first setting up a Blog she
began posting on her blog regularly
however even after regularly posting on
the blog there were barely any visitors
showing up deciding not to give up
Rachel began searching for a solution on
the internet that's when she came across
SEO or search engine optimization a term
she's never heard before so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO search engine optimization is
a method that could improve the quality
and quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO onpage and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle onpage
SEO and get that sorted onpage SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema metat Tags and More
she started off by using tools like
Google adwards alre and semrush to
identify popular Search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for Search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics once
she found these Search terms she began
to incorporate them into her recipes she
started off by providing an introduction
to the recipe with this she could
provide an engaging beginning to her
story like how the dish reminded her of
her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website meta content that searched
display when her blog appears in search
results she optimized The Meta tags alt
tags header Tags and More this completed
the onpage aspect of SEO thanks to this
she saw a significant increase in the
number of visitors coming to her page
having done all she could on her web
page she now decides to explore what
could be done off- page to improve her
Page's visibility on search engines
off-page SEO involved Rachel doing
things outside her site page to help
increase its search engine r rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked unlink
brand mentions influencer marketing and
much more Rachel also understood that
for her content to reach people she
would have to promote it on social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter and
Instagram as well as Niche platforms
like qu Reddit and medium these could
help her achieve greater reach for her
website by sending stronger social
signals to search engines leading to the
page being shown as highly relevant for
related searches and audiences and even
after understanding and implementing all
of this Rachel had just scratched the
surface of what was possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a Content two getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites three acquiring
backlinks through link buying four none
of the above let us know your answer in
the comment section below for a chance
to win an Amazon voucher now let's go
back to Rachel Rachel decided to take up
simply learn's digital marketing
certification with classes covering just
about everything she needed to know
about SEO it was only a matter of time
before Rachel began to implement her
learnings on her website and see a
massive uptick in the number of viewers
coming to her website in time she could
even earn money off the site by setting
up an online shop and with that we've
covered an introduction to the concepts
of SEO and the possibilities it can open
for you greetings everyone this is Rob
Sanders from Simply learn and today
we're going to talk about keyword
research so what what are we going to
talk about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step pizza recipes
with sausage homemade pizza toppings
pizza dough recipes th Crust Pizzas
she's doing a lot of different topics on
pizza recipes well what Jesse needs to
do is understand what's going to drive
traffic to these blog posts if she's
writing about you know different topics
around pizza recipes so she's Unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to understand that
hey you need to choose the right
keywords to drive traffic so the
question is if you're writing a a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and choosing the key words to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen are they could have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it could be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
align with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them in correct
correctly with your content so these are
some of the issues that you can
encounter if you just go about choosing
keywords randomly without due diligence
without the proper research so low
search volume will lead to less traffic
High competition you may not even rank
at all okay if somebody finds you for a
keyword that's not relevant to the topic
they're just going to leave the page and
if you're not using the right keywords
and or if you are using the right
keywords and not using them correctly in
the content then your pages may not even
be found in organic search so you really
have to take care and choosing the
keywords to me that's the most important
step with SEO is keyword research so
we're going to talk about the types of
keyword research then so we have short
tail keywords and we have long tail
keywords so if you write a blog post
about pizza recipes well what are you
going to choose a short tail or long
tail so let's talk about short tail
keywords first so short tail keywords
are are keywords that are usually three
keywords in a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two keywords in a phrase
or shorter so short tail keywords
usually have high search volume which
means likely means higher competition
but what it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tail keyword
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tail key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite in restaurant so short
tail keywords may not be as relevant so
if we compare it with longtail keywords
chances are you're going to have lower
competition that's one of the benefits
but you're also going to have lower
search volume but with longer tail
keywords the keyword is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short tail keywords and longtail
keywords if you want to look it
simplistically short-tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus longtail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is broaden nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long TI word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that sinky word and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long TIY word but if somebody's
looking for that type of pizza recipe
then you know you're going to track the
right traffic and chances are that
traffic is going to engage or convert
based on the type of conversion you have
in place so an example would be homemade
pizza dough recipes that'd be another
example more than think key word words
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
uh specific in nature longer tail so
these keywords are used for targeted
Pages including blog post if you're
writing a blog post specifically about
pizza recipes with homemade dough then
this is the keyword you likely would
want to use versus just pizza recipes so
let's look at an example between a short
tail keyword and a longtail keyword and
to accentuate the differences we're
going to use Google's Keyword Planner
tool so Google's Keyword Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly search seches this
is the average monthly search volume of
a key word over the past 12 months and
so in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is
33,100 for pizza recipe so note that
pizza recipe and pizza recipes are
closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties a pizza recipe then they're also in
Google's eyes looking for pizza recipes
so it's a close variance and so for the
keyword pizza recipe which is short tail
we could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received
33,100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically the
volume the average volume per month so
here I could see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is 33
1,000 and then I can see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the longtail keyword I can see
homemade pizza dough recipe again close
variance homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months what the
search volume is for this on average
is400 but I could see here in December
the volume went up to 3600 but for
example in May it was 1,00 so it's going
to fluctuate a bit over the past 12
months but on average it's about 2400 so
shorter tail lot more volume longer tail
not as much volume but nonetheless there
is volume here and so these are the
differences between a short tail and a
longer tail and so what Google's Keyword
Planner also does is allow us to get a
sense of what the competition is and so
here I can see the competition is low
for both of these keywords fair enough
so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword word remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2400
you're going to get a lion share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
Promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool in Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose key words based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
key word homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2400 a month and
search volume again we may not get all
2400 but are we're going to get a line
share of that we also need to look at
competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
ter terms of the competition but if
you're somebody who wants to get a
better sense of what the competition is
and you should because competition is a
key component in choosing keywords and
so what I want to do is get a sense of
how many people are actually optimizing
for that keyword so Google's Keyword
Planner tool is going to give me a low
medium high really what I want to do is
get a better sense of that numerically
so what I can do is go into Google's
search and I can type in pizza recipes
and I could see there's about 1 billion
results that's a lot of results however
that means that every potential web page
out there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all entitle syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
key word Pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all en tile colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336,000 so what that tells me is that
there are 336,000 results with the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
now if I want to focus in on my other
keyword if I choose uh my other keyword
was a longer tail keyword homemade pizza
dough recipe so if I type that keyword
in the homemade pizza dough recipe or
recipes remember close variance and I
just click enter or type the keyword in
hit my enter key I'm going to get 35
Million results but again is that really
an indicator of the type of competition
I have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
en tile colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many websit
sites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2,160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33,100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 th000 so I'm going to
type in
683 th000 what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 20 400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was if I type that keyword
back in 260 so I'm going to put
2,160 so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number keywords what you
do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition and if I make that a
percentage I can see it's 35% is the
ratio between volume and competition if
I do the same for my longer tail keyword
2400 / 2160 I can see that 111% so this
just kind of proves the point that yeah
I'm still going to get some volume but I
have a b better chance of ranking for
this longer teal keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes so you want to be able to
do that for number keywords and examine
the volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want to choose
keywords that are very relevant to the
content that you're writing and then
again commercial intent what keywords
are going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial commercial intent we're
talking about you know are you choosing
keywords that are going to get somebody
to do what you want them to do so we
could say You Know download pizza dough
recipes so if somebody's typing in the
keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your s and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're any Commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of of any particular Trend going
on or seasonality so for example if I
saw large growth in the winter months
and not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending how competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 and Google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all and
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will it keep the
traffic on your website but hopefully
get that traffic to engage and convert
so that's the key about relevancy you
always want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content even if it's
sacrificing volume relevancy again
trumps volume in competition so always
choose relevant keywords first so when
you do that you're always almost
guaranteeing that at some point
somebody's going to find your content
because somebody out there might be
looking for it and if they do you're
going to get found and then they engage
is going to be better so understand your
business find keywords that are relevant
to your business and then focus on those
key words that'll help you with getting
the right traffic to your site always
keep in mind the commercial intent so
these keywords are more specific and
result in conversion rate for example
buying is a good commercial intent
keyword so if you really want somebody
to come to your website and buy then
focus on those types of keywords in the
case of the pizza recipes maybe it's
download could be our commercial content
keyword again there may be low search
volume but those are the type of
keywords you want to focus on because
that's the type of traffic you want to
drive to your site so some other
examples like commercial intent keywords
or discount deal your coupon shipping
you don't don't be afraid to use some of
these keywords as part of your longer
tail keyword phrase again the volume may
not be high but the traffic quality is
probably going to be better so keyword
research is the foundation for SEO so if
you have chosen your keywords properly
then if you do get ranked for those
keywords then it's going to lead to
better engagement with some conversions
and so when we talk about keywords we
also want to talk about our primary and
secondary keyword so every page should
have at least a primary keyword and then
a secondary keyword to work with so
primary keywords are really defining the
nature of your content the secondary
keywords are relevant to the primary
keyword so why do we choose a primary
and secondary keyword because you may
choose a keyword as a primary keyword
that is relevant to the content but may
not necessarily rank very high or have a
lot of volume that secondary keyword is
also relevant to the primary keyword but
also relevant to content and you may
rank for that secondary keyword so you
always want to go with two keywords
versus just one keyword want to give
your yourself a chance to rank for at
least two different types of keywords of
relevant name nature so for web page
there can be several secondary keywords
but only one primary keyword so your
primary keyword is always going to be
relevant to your content secondary
keywords can be relevant to the keyword
but and you may have multiple secondary
keywords but it's also going to be
related to the content and it gives you
a better opportunity to be found between
both the primary and secondary in search
Okay so let's take a look at another
example of how to use primary keyword
and secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to co Google's Keyword Planner
tool and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy meal plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google's
Keyword Planner and type those keywords
in I'm going to choose get results and
now here I can see healthy diet plan
keyword I'm focusing on as my primary
keyword has an average monthly search
volume of
99,900 and then some of my secondary
keyword healthy diet foods diet plan
weight loss low carb diet you know
Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan I go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan
99,900 what's my competition so my
competition is
74,700 and that's going to give me a
ratio a volume competition of 13% so
that's what my content's about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 133% and what I want to do is I
want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key at
least two keywords I want to be able to
find my primary keyword that's relevant
to my content and then I want to be able
to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again of how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like Kora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword word and then secondary keywords
that are similar to the primary keyword
and usually those are LSI or latent
semantic indexing type keywords so
they're used to drive relevant traffic
to your page so if you're focusing on
one keyword we want to have other
keywords that are similar to increase
our visibility on the search engine
result pages so we could find latent
semantic indexing right in search so if
we use the term healthy diet if we go to
Google search for example if I type in
healthy diet in Google search all I need
to do is scroll to the bottom of the
page and I can see searches related to
healthy diet so healthy diet menu
healthy diet essay what does a healthy
diet look like notice at the top
Google's also given me some other
suggestions here so they're saying
lowfat diet veganism gluten-free diet so
there's lots of different suggestions
right in Google search bar so all of
these are LSi related keywords so if
you're optimizing a page for healthy
diet then you could choose lowfat diet
as a secondary keyword you can use
gluten-free diet as a secondary keyword
it really depends on what the content is
but you always want to support your
content with as much LSI keywords as
possible so you can be found for as many
different keywords as possible in Google
search so it's important because if you
have a Blog that you know talks about
python so how do the search engine know
if the website python is about the
programming language or the snake so
Google for example uses LSI keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on Python and your content you want to
support that with LSI keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a keyword I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of questions
are being asked what Mals are good for
weight loss what is a good healthy diet
plan all of these could be keyword
phrases that you can use so the answers
are right here in Google so core is a
great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about cor is it's a good it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing Kora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant key
words to healthy dieting so if you just
type in that particular keyword in Kora
you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy diet
what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
some responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and both well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If scroll down I could see
some related LSI keywords at the bottom
so writing Google as well you could see
in the Google search bar that Google
provides some LSI related keywords to
your query so if I go back here and type
in healthy diet recipes I can see here
Google suggesting some other related
keywords healthy diet menu healthy diet
for men healthy diet foods healthy diet
for women so these are all LSI related
keywords that you can use to support
your primary keyword and the content
you're writing about so we've talked
about LSI keywords where to find them so
they're found right here they could be
found at the top of Google and they can
be found at the bottom you can also then
go to chorus as well and get some ideas
for the types of questions they're being
asked so if you ask a question and use
that as your keyword phrase then again
you have an opportunity of showing up
for a featured snippet in Google just by
doing some additional research within
Google itself or on Kora so according to
Google the autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for term so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own Advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the metad
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
Wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we could take a look at keywords from
the Wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional Pages like the see
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so we go
to Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I can
see also section so it might give me
some information food information to
Consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you go no further
than the c alsoa section the referencing
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags
and the Ser so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so and Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so
keyword it is the average monthly
searches for particular keyword so if we
type a Word in key rdit and choose
keywords from the autogenerator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant and the
search volume of that keyword so if I
just type in healthy food keyworded tool
is going to tell me some relevant
keywords and what the volume is so if
you don't have the Keyword Planner tool
in Google ads available to you this is a
good alternative solution to finding
keywords so it's free you just need to
go to keyword it.com type in your
keyword click get keywords and what it's
going to do is give you some relevant
keywords related to your primary keyword
with the search volume let's talk about
keyword clustering now so the whole idea
about keyword clustering is to really
take advantage of the keywords that
we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and that theme of
keywords is relevant to a specific page
of a website then we have a better
opportunity to rank so in other words
why do we have to Target just one
keyword when we can Target many so keep
in mind you know LSI keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for Content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to the
court theme what is SEO another cluster
of key words for example could be SEO
techniques SEO best practices tips and
tricks website optimization onpage SEO
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news so brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords I
a theme of keywords that you can cluster
together and then you could determine
the keywords that your competitors are
already ranking for so for example if we
want to rank for the keyword SEO best
practices for example we can use a tool
called keyword MZ if I go to keyword the
keyword Explorer tool in MZ and just
type in SEO best practices what it's
going to do is it's going to give me
some volume related to that particular
keyword but more importantly what it's
also going to do is going to show me
what pages are already ranked for that
particular keyword so therefore I can
get a sense of who is already ranking
for that keyword so here I can see MZ M
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself SEO is an
important part of the marketing strategy
in case your website doesn't show up on
the first page of the search engine then
you need to work on it to solve all your
SEO related problems we've come up with
the solution welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel and today we will be
discussing the top 10 tips that every
marketer needs to know so let's get
started and see the first step the first
step is voice search now voice search
will impact search queries in 2021
according to dialog tech.com
in the United States of America 55% of
the households will have their own smart
speaker by
2022 well that's a lot so if you're
planning to optimize your voice search
consider choosing wise keywords
find out longer phrases that Searchers
use in daily life
conversation voice search is a more
suitable way for searching long and more
natural sounding phrases creating
detailed and relevant answers are
essential when optimizing for voice
search so always remember to create
Persona based content next create web
pages that can answer FAQ use because
when Searchers ask a question they begin
their question with words like who when
what however there are many reasons for
using voice search such as dictating
text messages looking for a video on
YouTube calling a person from your
contact list asking for directions Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows way websites
on top that load quickly in that case
you must always ensure that your website
has a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is
reduced now the second step in the
process is the mobile
optimization now you must already know
how important important it is to make
your site mobile friendly for a better
user experience but did you also know
that having a mobile friendly
application impacts your search engine
optimization sem Rush confirms that by
the year 2025 approximately 70% of
Internet users will access the internet
through mobile devices Google's mobile
friendly update has resulted in a big
change in search rankings with the help
of Google's free mobile friendly test
have a look at how effective your mobile
website is also take a peek at the
mobile usability report in Google's
search console now let's talk about tip
number three that is Google's eight
principles Google has confirmed that
content quality is an essential factor
for ranking on search engine result
pages but what does quality mean to
Google well content that fulfills the
Google eat principle will rank high
e stands for expertise authoritativeness
and
trustworthiness these elements will
determine if a web page has a useful
quality content Google uses the
combination of algorithms to deliver the
best results for users Google Panda is
one of the famous algorithms of Google
which emphasizes delivering highquality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have low quality and
duplicate content not just that there is
one more algorithm called rank brain
rankbrain is a processing algorithm that
uses machine learning to interpret
search queries that users search on
Google whereas the searched query may
not have the right keywords that were
searched
for for example when you're searching
for chocolate cake recipes you will also
get results for chocolate truffle cake
recipes on the search engine results
page Google Panda and rank brain send
bot to crawl each and every website and
as a result shows highquality content on
the top of the search engine results
page next is our tip number four
featured
snippet these results are featured on
the top part of the page Google
programmatically chooses the best answer
from the third-party website and
displays it on the featured snippet
here's what a featured snippet looks
like according to ah refs for a specific
search search query almost 99% of web
pages shown in the featured snippet
already rank on sep's first page some of
the ways to optimize featured Snippets
are organize your content in a
structured way make sure one article
answers many similar questions use
eye-catching images and the last point
is to create answers with tables to
drive clicks and write dedicated
headings to answer featured Snippets
like is red meat healthy suppose you
want to create Snippets plan on creating
question-based questions along with the
relevant keywords for ideas you can also
look at the Google search function that
is usually written in the blue color and
it reads out as people also ask so now
let's move to the fifth tip image
optimization according to sem Rush image
optimization will play a prominent role
in search in case the images on your
website aren't optimized make sure to
take care of them right now remember to
use highquality images relevant images
and use a suitable label for your image
file include images in your sit map as
it becomes easier for the Bots to crawl
and finally use alt tags as crawlers use
it to classify the images alt text is
displayed on the web page when an image
fails to load on a user screen
it is also utilized by Google to drive
meaning from images a well optimized
image can improve your page ranking and
increase the engagement on it image
optimization can help your web page show
up in the image carousels on search
engines next we have semantically
related
keywords semantic search will have
become an important factor for ranking
in the future semantic keywords are
linked to the primary keywords they
drive relevant traffic on search engine
result Pages a simple way to look for
LSI keywords is on Google
sep semantic search can be performed
wisely by writing content that targets
the question that your target audience
is looking for remember to optimize
content for topic clusters instead of
focusing solely on keywords and finally
use structured data and pick your
semantic keywords this can also be done
with the help of a comprehensive keyword
tool it finds out semantically related
keywords next comes tip number seven
building quality links building quality
links to your website is important if
you are aiming to manage a successful
and long-term SEO strategy building
quality links cannot be ignored in 2016
Google declared that building quality
links are one of their top three ranking
signals always opt for quality over
quantity as building quality links to
your content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in
scps let me share a few effective
strategies that will increase the number
of links pointing to your website
dramatically the first one earn back
links from relevant and authoritative
web pages next promote your content
regularly on social media op for guest
blogging and influencer marketing next
take advantage of social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter Instagram and
start your own page then participate in
forums to engage with your target
audience start your blog and attract
your target audience with your valuable
content finally get listed in the
highquality link directories this will
help you build links from authoritative
websites next number eight is local
search
listings local SEO is the practice of
optimizing a website in order to obtain
traffic from location-based searching it
is the best way to Market your products
and services to local
customers according to Google local
results are based on relevance distance
and prominence these factors help Google
to find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your na P details accurate and
consistent across the
internet sem Rush confirms that local
search listings will play a larger role
in the SEO
strategies suppose you want to know how
to get your business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own for this it is also important
to have a strong backlink
profile next we have number nine that is
improve the user experience for the past
few years ux has become an important
ranking factor for Google however more
and more SEO Specialists have gained an
interest in
ux ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor consider the
partnership of search engine
optimization and user
experience this way the search engine
optimization focuses on search engines
and user experience Target website
visitors so both share a common goal of
giving users the best result this is
what the content King app says about the
user
experience let me show you a few
practices on how to effectively leverage
ux designs to provide your site's SEO
performance simplify your site's
navigation a good site architecture
helps to gain traffic utilize ux design
to SEO friendly layouts which means make
content easy to digest infused images
and videos whenever possible use ctas
very
wisely and finally optimize for Sight
load speed optimize for mobile
responsive design as more than 50% of
all the traffic is now driven by mobile
search in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement and finally we come to our
10th and last
tip that is using schema
markup according to search metrics 36%
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schemo markup schemo markup is Micro
Data that every individual can add to
his website in order to give an enhanced
description to users on a search engine
results page in simple words schema
markup is used to define website
content adding structured data will give
your website a significant SEO boost and
increase your
rankings some of the schema markup
examples are ratings and reviews image
thumbnails product availability and
finally site links adding schema mark up
to your HTML is one of the ranking
factors hello everyone welcome to this
new video by simply learn search engine
optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before we
begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold so definitely we're going to
take a look at the best tips for ranking
high on Google but before that it is
necessary to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google well we
are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business the
data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as Surs allows a
business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales it also helps in
generating authenticity for your
business well not one or two there are
numerous reasons which makes SEO
important to know more about SEO check
the complete playlist on SEO you can
find the link to the playlist in the
description box below to gain expertise
in search engine optimization get
certified as a skilled SEO professional
with simply learns search engine
optimization training course you can
check the course details from the link
in the description box below as we know
how important it is to rank high on
Google so in the next 10 minutes let's
get to know the top five success mantras
that will help you rank high in Google
so the fifth tip on our list is promote
your content whether you are a business
owner or a blogger you definitely need
to promote your content to get a good
audience reach by content here we mean
data on your website that can be
products services or even a simple blog
to do this find the relevant groups on
the social media platforms like Facebook
or Instagram and post your content with
an excellent call to action context some
blogging or article submission sites
like Kora Tumblr and hub pages may also
prove helpful online forums and
communities can be a good option to
spread a word about your content with
people having similar interests let's
focus on our number four tip internal
linking a good site architecture is
always a happy bite for webcrawlers a
website with good site architecture and
internal linking helps webcrawlers
understand the website structure and
helps them to crawl the site more
effectively the more the pages of your
website are crawled greater are the
chances of getting indexed if pages are
successfully indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the back link
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a back Link in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below at number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results onpage
optimization onpage optimization or also
known as onpage SEO is a process in
which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web Page's
position in search engine rankings
onpage optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more get the detail guide to learning
onpage optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research keyword research is a process
of identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create proper keyword research
may prove a boon to your business but it
also has the power to ruin your business
so be wise When selecting your keywords
try choosing longtail keywords if you
are new to the business as these are
easier to rank for you can look at
Google's Autos suggest feature to
understand what people are looking for
in your industry be updated with what
your competitors are doing if something
is working for your competitor there are
high chances that it may work for you as
well you can also take the help of
various keyword research tools like
Google's own Keyword Planner answer the
public tool Google Trends and Etc these
fantastic and 100% practical tips can
drive your business to
make sure you implement all these tips
with more detailed attention as SEO can
make and break you so what according to
you is the most effective way to grow
your business online let us know in the
comments below hey guys welcome to
today's session my name is Sachin seel
and I'm here to talk about a very
important tool Google ads and out of all
the ads we can create under Google ads
today we would be talking about a very
important one Google search and so this
is going to be very exciting this is
going to be very deep from my experience
I can say I will going to take you
through a lot of technical aspects and
lot of uh optimization strategies where
you can really bring down the cost down
if you're really paying high for your
clicks and conversion so please be with
me and I would try to give you the best
from my site great so let's just start
guys Google ads is something which we
have discussed in the last class if you
have seen my last session if you have
not we will leave the link in the
description where we talked about the
basics of Google ads and we also talked
about how to create this beautiful ad
account or a tool with a free Gmail ID
okay we did talked about few more things
that how many types of ads you can
create just to give you the quick
Glimpse we are on Google and when we
type something like if I want to do a
data analytics
course so I would type few things like a
word or a keyword or a quiry into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called text ad or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online so then there would be results
but in a different shape and color and
different structure there is an ad which
is a text ad but on the top we are able
to see some more ads but they are not
just text they have a pricing they have
a title they have a brand name they have
a image of the product so they are
called shopping ads or product listing
ads in addition to that sometimes you
know when you go to a product uh a
website like speed test and you see the
product ads
there but again in the different shape
and color so they are called display ads
because they've been displayed on
different websites and different apps so
why I'm going so fast in explaining you
different type of ads because as I told
you we have another video created uh
with the name of uh Google ads uh for
beginners 2023 you can just check the
link in the description and you will
able to get all this type of ads and
whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just as
to show you if you can see that adds by
Google so this is the display ad or a
banner just quickly I have shown you
three types of the ads but our Focus as
I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which is the most important
ad from the Google ads family okay so
let's just begin
guys when I come to Google ads this is
how the Google ads structure looks
like we have a Google ads account
created again I repeat if you don't know
how to create it please find the link in
the description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if you are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learn Google ads manager so
I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply learn
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simply
learn ad here so dat analytics course
India and then probably we can see if
there are any you can always change the
keywords but just to test I'm uh
randomly changing the words or I could
have just written simply Lear
specifically because I want to go with
simply only I have researched a lot and
I feel like this is one of the best okay
so probably there is no add
though still I will
check probably have to just change the
codes so I will go for the another
course which is by simply learn again
and then probably we can expect any of
the ads
running because this is not a very peak
time so we are probably you know saving
some of the cost not running the ads at
this all hour anyhow so we can assume
that this is the ad you know I am
running for so how we can create this ad
how we can get the best of clicks as I
said it is not a very best time to run
the ad so this is also kind of a change
you know we can bring into our ads by
doing some research so how all these
things are done we're going to be
learning it okay so when we come here to
the dashboard and then we see our
dashboard looks like this a bit
complicated so we can be confused we can
be disheartened that I have created the
account by seeing uh the first video but
now I am all stuck okay so probably I
have to again wait so the wait is over
now we are here to understand the whole
structure okay so let me just take a
very simple example suppose I uh am
someone who selling a shoes okay because
I have just said simply Lear probably
let's just convert it to any of the
Google ads account of a shoe seller
probably I'm Nike okay and I am making
the ad for Nike shoes and I am selling
uh two types of the Nike shoes today
probably formal or Canvas OR probably
I'm selling the casual or any sports
shoes and what I did I created the
campaign named it search ad uh any month
you know whatever the month you have
started with suppose November so
November 2022 that is the name which I'm
giving name can be changed name is
something which is been puted up for my
reference so that after creating lot of
campaigns I'm not confused in which
campaign I have to check the results
okay so I'm running the search chart for
shoes for the month of February or
November or December 22 23 whatever and
then I open two ad groups into it why
I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I'm
selling formal also under the shoes only
I'm selling casual also so what happen
suppose I would have just you know
created one at group and would have
inserted or uh submitted all the
keywords of formal and Casual inside one
ad group then if somebody would have
searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal ad
shoes or should I show casual ad shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mixed of the keywords from
formal and Casual family into the same
ad group the moment any of these six
keywords being typed or been searched on
Google then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again again randomly
it would have shown the ad of a formal
or ad of a casual because both of the
ads would have been under this okay but
after doing uh this bif foration or
after doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here this ad
group would trigger if any of this
keyword would searched and accordingly
this ad which has everything related to
only formal shoes will be shown and of
course with that ad the landing page
which is connected which uh would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and wi of Versa if somebody
would have searched for a casual term
like a casual shoes sports shoes jogging
shoes running shoes then this ad group
would have triggered and then the casual
shoes ad with all the headline related
to that casual keywords would have been
shown and accordingly if somebody would
have clicked then the landing page of
casual shows uh you know would have
opened okay so if this is clear actually
you are very much ready to uh dive into
the Google ads because many people takes
a lot of time to understand the
structure because uh you know maybe they
are very much confused at the ad group
level but I have just tried my level
best by bringing this example why I am
creating two different ad groups why I'm
not just going with the same ad group
you know mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been or a
second permutation could have been I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign all together and I would have
named it campaign search ad casual shoes
November then this second campaign or a
second campaign can be assumed here with
you know with a green color would have
been drawn okay so this is how on the
structure it works like we can always
now create inside so let's just see a
few things uh before we create the ad
okay very important uh requirement or
rather I would say uh if being the
campaign manager of any any any any any
company you name any startup you name or
any client you work with or probably for
yourself as well you have to be very
much sure how these terms works like
Okay so this terms when I talk about is
going to be bit inclined towards the
search CH today only and when I talk
about the display ad in the next video
then I would you know take you through
about the terminologies and all the kpis
of display Banner or a video ads okay so
now if I talk about a search ad a very
important um term which we should be
aware of is the maximum bid price okay
because we all know when we talking
about this ad which is called a text ad
then we are paying on every click okay
that's why this is also called PPC ad
this is also called PPC marketing or you
can understand in a very simple words uh
Advertiser which uh is emiritus this in
this particular ad only has to pay when
somebody like such In This Moment
clicking this ad I click this ad I reach
to the landing page of this particular
University or this college and a certain
amount is deducted from this particular
ad account and that certain amount
actually decides or decided on the basis
of the keyword helped to show this ad
okay so as an Advertiser must have paid
something to Google ads for showing this
ad for this keyword okay so when I say a
maximum bid price it means means it's a
maximum B price of a keyword that's why
now this would be easier to understand
by this example suppose I want to run
the ad on the term called data analytics
course
2022 what I did I have opened the Google
Keyword Planner you know I did talked
about this in the previous session but I
will take you through again how you use
a Keyword Planner smartly so I have got
this data from the keywords planner that
the average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bided something over
the minimum bid price okay this is the
minimum bit price this is the maximum
bit price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take um chance maybe 30 40%
over the minimum bid range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bit price but
coming back to the terminologies what we
talking here is once I have seted up my
maximum bid price of 7 rupees then my ad
would start showing suppose my ad shows
for thousand times today and every time
when my ad being CED you know certain
amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertisers
also you know who are running the ad and
after showing my ad for the whole day
Google in the dashboard just shown that
you have paid average CPC of 5 rupees
only so I bid it for seven but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in been paying 5 rupees for every
Click by the end of a day so the average
CPC sometimes you know people get
confused the have a CPC and the maximum
bid price the same no so maximum bid
price is something which I uh you know
submit to Google that this is the
maximum I can pay for my add to show on
certain keyword for every click and a
CPC is something which actually you know
I pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration your ad got
displayed or got clicks uh for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword uh submitted and
suppose I've got 100 clicks then you
know it's a simple math that my budget
which I have spent today is 5 rupees for
one click 500 rupees for 100 click so
daily budget would be 500 rupees and
tomorrow if company says I need 300
clicks then of course my uh average CPC
which I have from the historical data of
yesterday yesterday you know I would
just do my maths and I will going to
submit the daily budget of not 100
rather 300 today so that in, 1500 I can
expect 300 clicks at the cost of 5
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example to just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh the screenshots over
so your Keyword Planner opens and then
you discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
codes and then I'll click the get result
and then accordingly it will show me lot
of of options and this is the pricing I
was talking about it gives me the low
price and the high price so I would take
the 30 40% over the low bit price or the
average price between these both and
that would be my maximum bid price and
after checking all the permutations
Google would show my ad or either it
would not show my ad also there can be a
chance so I have to just wait for my
impression and clicks and the results by
the end of a day and I would you know I
would know uh how much the average CPC
actually I'm paying for
each keyword okay so I'll show you all
those reports in a while uh that's it
right now let's just go and see few
things so the Keyword Planner will start
with suppose I start um you know in
researching all these things my campaign
is about data analytics course I'm
making it for simply probably and I
would go and I would just try to you
know search in the planning my Keyword
Planner and then I will write a term
quickly here you know what whatever I
want to show my ad for suppose data
analytics course as I
said okay probably let's say digital
marketing because we would have
more uh results so it's easy to
understand with a lot of results because
I would able to tell you how to sort and
filter them down uh disal marketing
course and you can just test it with any
of the keywords I'm just doing a random
check so once we are here we have lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know um
monthly searches and uh of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the you
know in the month of 2021 to September
2022 so this is actually the average
monthly searches happened in between
this period and uh the advertise is
actually paid as low as 44 Rupees to as
high 224 rupees okay that can easily be
uh you know converted to dollars uh half
a dollar or maybe more than half a
dollar uh 6070 cents probably and uh
this is like going to be a $3 cost okay
so what we can do is we can see now
there are a lot of keywords been given
and we can easily sort them down here on
certain you know basis like you know
suppose the monthly searches are high or
the bid is low and all that stuff but
this is quite you know difficult when we
have to sort down here in the Keyword
Planner so what I do is I'm just going
to talk about the same you know like hi
how I actually go when I am working for
my clients okay I have clients here a
lot of clients I don't want to show you
but yeah I have and um suppose I just go
and download this data from here and
then this would be you know uh
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword
sheet and I would have a data in my
Excel okay so I need this this one so
this is the most important column
because I have to highlight uh which
column is important and what is not
required right now so whatever is
required I'm just I'll be keeping with
me and what I feel like is not very
important as of now I'm just not going
to be taking them so now there are five
column which I have kept with myself
like these four where we talk about the
results and the keyword okay uh this is
not required this is not required I'm
just going to be deleting or hiding them
okay so when we talk about a competition
index value so this actually tells us
that a particular keyword is how much um
you know from the competition point of
view is difficult to rank suppose supp I
talk about two key ones right now let me
just take um one with a lower score
suppose this one and I would take the
higher or the highest one probably is
this one okay so now when I talk about a
comparison you know probably uh or or
probably let's say this this one because
this has monthly searches which are
equivalent uh you know from the uh
competition point of view they are very
different but the search has been same
so if I would stuck to something of this
sort if I have to finalize between these
two so what I would do you know that
that's something which we are talking
here you know if we have a kind of a
combination where we have to decide out
of these two so both of uh the keywords
mean very important if I would just
check from my naked eye a quick Scan
they look very promising they look very
great to me suppose and they have a
equivalent number of searches in the
last you know one year on the average
monthly basis but there is a difference
between the compet comption okay now
people can be confused what is this
competition so I would just make you
explain in a very simpler way Suppose
there are 100 companies or there are 100
you know e tech institutes or probably
physical institutes who teaches uh
digital marketing because we are doing
online marketing or you know digital
marketing course online so so let's keep
it uh online uh institutes like simply
learn and all okay so what they have
done is in the last one year they all
have used these keywords to run their
ads you know to show their uh
advertisement or their digital ad on a
Google space okay when this data has
been given so this is telling me that
out of those 100 advertisers or my 100
competitors 66 or a
66% advertisers have used this ad okay
or have used this keyword to show their
ad okay and out of 100 33 % or if it is
100 uh then 33 advertisers have used
this keyword to show their ad okay so it
brings you know kind of a uh comparison
to US that probably these two keywords
are very much in demand you know like uh
equally from the searches point of view
because both have been searched equally
but whenever this has been searched then
there has been a competition where 66
people or 66 advertisers or 66%
advertisers are fighting to show their
ad okay and when this keyword being
searched as equally then only 33% or 33
people or 33 advertisers are fighting to
show their ad on Google space okay when
I talk about 100 then that seems to be
okay where my ad would look like you
know where my ad would show because if I
just go on a Google space you know that
only seven ads are shown when you know
when we go on a Google search engine 1 2
3 and four and then the rest three would
be at the bottom if they are shown at
this moment or not I'm not very sure so
three would be here somewhere so total
seven ads placement on the first page
nobody goes beyond first we know that 97
of the worldwide audience don't don't go
beyond the first page ination okay so we
have to be on our first page so if I
talk about from the first page seven
positions point of view it would make
more sense so let's imagine there are
only 10 advertisers of digital marketing
course so out of 10 if I take out 66 66%
then it means almost like six to seven
advertisers are fighting or have bided
or probably are trying to outrank each
other to show their ad on the top or on
the first four positions of Google but
when I talk about this then only three
to four advertisers are fighting or have
bidded for this keyword to show the ad
on the first first page so this actually
is a very important data sometimes we
just you know Miss it because uh it has
not been uh I think explained anywhere
else that what exactly this value is we
only go by the low medium high which is
the very first column I delete nowadays
you know I don't you know go by this
because they both come under the medium
but there's a big difference you know 7
out of 10 would have been bided for and
only three to four would have been bided
for this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
because that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of U index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bid
value or a bid uh price which is also on
a very lower side not a very high price
key would we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bit price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30% to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30% to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
the first day if the Impressions has
come it means my price actually been
accepted but if any of the keyword my
price is not accepted then I would again
revise the price by 20 30% and then
would wait for the second day report and
that's how you know I keep changing for
the first 2 3 days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know start getting the stable results
then I uh just as allow the campaign to
work uh you know on the algorithm and uh
you know I I see uh results actually
moves in the positive direction when you
give some time to campaigns to read and
to learn uh you know from the audience
Behavior okay so this is about the
keyword planning which we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted to
to speak on all these technical aspects
you know which works at the back end so
that's why my focus is more on this uh
presentation par I would keep showing
you the uh you know uh the uh Google ads
uh the demo and everything okay so now
when we move to the next part next part
is very important from the um ad
algorithm point of view so what happens
or what used to happen uh when when the
quality score you know which I'm just
trying to speak now was not there
uh what used to happen the one who used
to pay the highest bid price used to get
the first position and the second one
used to get the second position and the
third bidder used to get the third
position so I have just brought into
this table suppose a Advertiser has
bided 8 rupee B 10 C15 and
D20 and when the quality score concept
was not there so they actually been
given the very direct position this one
first this one second this one third and
this one fourth but they have realized
or Google has realized that the one who
is paying the most is not having a very
good quality of the ad uh his uh landing
page or the website it's is not working
or probably the pages which is which are
connected are not very relevant and the
keywords on which the ads been shown is
nowhere near uh you know when the
landing page is opened so it it was like
a very negative impact on Google when
the reviews been checked and people or
the users who were clicking on those ads
were not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check uh which is called
quality score for every keyword we bid
okay and this is only for the search ads
that's why I said all the keywords we
bid okay I'll just show you the result
on a client site so when we submit our
ad on the basis of you know different
keyword we bu and and the strategy we
use and the landing page we connected
the back end so what the system does is
system starts an izing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every uh Advertiser here
is bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let's um assume that they all are
running the ad for the digital marketing
course so what would happen they would
check and on the basis of the you know
factors they would give us score out of
10 suppose the a Advertiser who bid it
for the least had the best of the
quality score because of the reasons
we're just going to talk about B got8
out of 10 four out of 10 and two out of
10 so the one who have bided the most
got the very least quality score
probably the reasons you know would be
more clear once we talk so how this now
we going to impact the whole position
system is that their Google rank not
Google position okay there is a Google
rank kind of a uh kPa can be understood
or a metrix which is um a product or a
multiplication of what you bid and how
much quality score you were able to get
so 8 into 9 brings 72 10 into 8 brings
80 15 into 4 brings 60 and 20 into 2 is
40 okay so the combination of a good
pricing and a good quality score got B
bidder as a first position okay and the
one who got the best quality score but
still paying very less from the average
pricing prob
is you know brought the Google position
or ad position to Second and then the
one who was spraying very high but the
quality score was below average which is
of course 56 is average price average
score they've got into third position
and the one who was paying so high
probably would not get a position
because this is the maths from the maths
point of view I've got these numbers if
the quality score would have been below
five then the ad would not have got any
position rather because Google always
tries to you know show the ads which are
the best uh for the users you know
because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users um uh you know expectations so and
when I said that I think you would able
to understand more now how the factors
you know which which actually results in
these quality score is um like relevant
score like by relevant score means when
you type A quiry or a person would come
here would type A quiry so he doesn't
know that this is called called a
keyword we as a digital marketers know
this is called a keyword for them it is
a normal query because they are about to
start a course where they would be
taught about all these things but right
now to they are not very aware you know
very much aware of these things so they
are putting a query when they put a
query they want to see the ad or add
extensions or add description relevant
to what they have search And when they
see all these three things here with the
search uh you know what they made they
would definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody's clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or a first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to the query and to whatever being shown
outside they cannot just show anything
here uh which is not relevant to the ad
which has actually been shown outside so
all these uh you know uh factors uh in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is
CTR which you must have understood when
you know we uh I I did you know explain
in the last session the basic one but if
you do not aare of it so CTR is called
click through rate okay and a click-
through rate is a ratio of clicks to
impression okay it is a ratio of clicks
to
impression just a spell check okay so
suppose
today uh when we are saying a BC D so
let's see this this is a or this is B
and this is C and they've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay they their
landing page their uh ad their
description everything is very much
common so Google in the starting of the
day you know when the ad actually
started to show for everyone uh you know
given them a very good quality score
probably of five okay and when this
quality score of five been given to them
then the other factor which actually
adds on you know to that algorithm is
the CTR so CTR is I just told you is the
ratio between click to impression so now
they all have a same quality score
but this got 100 clicks out of the
Thousand Impressions been given today
this got 50 clicks out of the th000
Impressions given today this got by any
mean probably 200 clicks out of the
th000 Impressions given today okay every
time this this search is happening here
digital marketing course so these three
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks this got 50 clicks
and this got 200 Clicks in the very
first hour or maybe in the next 2 hours
okay so this CTR you know when we are
talking about 100 out of 1,000 to 10%
This Is 50 out of th000 it means this is
going to be 5% and 20 uh sorry 200 out
of th000 means 20% of the CTR so Google
was actually benefited or made the most
of the revenue when know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of of course you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from 5
to 7 and this would you know probably
from 5 to 5.5 and this probably from 5
to six so because of that quality score
has improved and uh you know because of
the high CTR this ad has got so this
position will be changed and this would
know probably would get the first
position the second position and at the
end of a day this ad has to pay or
Advertiser has to pay lesser because
it's qualty score increase we have just
seen it is you know almost like the uh
you know inversely proportional the ones
who are actually paying or the ones who
are having the best of the quality score
are paying the least or has to pay the
least okay so this is all basically you
know can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the client's
account uh where you can just see this
with you know bit
better understanding you would be able
to get out of
this hopefully I able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have multi
mle advertisers you know but I cannot
just show for all so let me just check
if I can show you from any of the older
one just wait it is actually asking me
some
verification it's taking too much
time yeah it's just done now
okay so once this is done
so I will just take you to one of the
accounts where my main focus would be to
just show you how the quality score
report look like and then you know you
will get a fair idea what all the
factors you have to be focusing to bring
your qualty score high or to take your
qualty score high
okay so I'm just going to open the
search ads because we're talking about a
search ad here only and suppose if I
just go into the this uh Campaign which
is of course you know not running right
now but I just want to show you how to
check the report and all suppose this is
the campaign you have run for and you
got 75 clicks at a you know um average
CPC price of 40 PESA and you have just
given this much pricing and I have bid
it for many keywords but I want to see
which keyword had got the best of the
quality score and how the quality score
been given and all okay so once you
reach to the keyword report here you
know at this level then you see um uh
you know uh the kpis or metrics here
which gives equality score out of 10
okay you can see here very well and
every keyword being given you know if if
there are 10 keywords I don't know how
many keywords we bided for we bided 50
keywords okay and um you know you can
see all the keywords here and every
keyword been given the quality score out
of 10 okay because their CTR which was
the last part which I've explained you
the ratio between the impression two
clicks got the above average so they
give uh below average average and above
average so above average is best
actually for any of the factors so the
CTR is above average the landing page is
above average and their add is above
average means all are perfect then they
got the 10 the moment anything goes
below average or probably to the average
suppose you can see this is above
average for them this is above average
for them but their landing page
experience from this keyword point of
view is only average their quality score
has come to eight okay if you go go
further down uh let's see anything where
two of them yeah so here the kids ride
on is a keyword where CTR is also not as
high or as great you know to as compared
to the other keywords which we have seen
and also the landing page is not as
relevant to the keyword so there uh two
factors like CTR and landing page has
come to average as compared to the and
events which is above average so their
whole quality score got impacted which
actually came down from 10 to 8 and then
7 for this particular keyword and last
not least if I just take you to
somewhere where something is below
average has come now one is above
average one is okay they're getting
clicks but probably the ad is still not
very much relevant to the keyword okay
so they are below average above average
average has brought the quality score to
6 out of 10 it certainly would have you
know impacted on the cost and also to
the position okay so this is is
something which you would see when you
come here also you can check one more
thing here suppose you have bided for
your keyword and your bid price where
you are paying for is maximum bid price
let me just see where that column is so
otherwise I would just add that column
so that you can learn that part as
well
[Music]
okay just wait okay so this is basically
CPC price is being given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so got 623 you can
just check the mats it's always good to
cross check so 249 clicks multiplied by
the CPC price which is 2.50 rupe would
give you 6 22.5 which is the cost you
know for the keywords um you know we bid
it for and the total clicks we have paid
okay and the maximum bid price suppose
you know you have got uh the maximum bid
price of uh 1 rupe and you paid 17 PESA
1.66 and all and then what happens you
want to secure your position suppose the
very first page bid you're seeing that
you're getting the position but you're
not getting on a first page then here
because this campaign is not running so
I'm just giving you the hypothetical
example so whatever the pricing you
would have given for the particular
keyword suppose we talk about these
three keywords right now or particular
one keyword I suppose so this is
something which I'm know trying to show
on a one rupe cost but to show on the
first page it is saying that you have to
pay 1.5 okay to show on the uh first
four positions here 1 2 3 4 it is saying
that probably you have to pay 2.5 and to
get the absolute first position position
which is going to be the topmost it
would tell you that you have to probably
pay 5 rup you know you're paying one it
is asking 1.5 the first four it can be
paid for 2.53 or this has to be five so
you can always go and change your you
know bid price for the particular
keyword okay so there are ways to do it
suppose if I just go here and I just go
to the edit I can change my maximum CPC
bid price for this particular bid or a
keyword like to 5 rup okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that particular keyword
and I have made the change to this
particular keyword to 5 rupe so if you
know the average price was one and I was
not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or first absolute position
and I want because this is the most
important keyword for me then I would
just come here and would check the
pricing okay this says 5 rupees you have
to pay for the top position so I will
just just go here edit and would change
the bid price or a maximum CPC bid price
of this particular keyword you can do
for all you know you have to just of
course you know select all of course but
if you would do for all then it it can
really impact your whole budget okay so
try to go for the keywords where you
really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure my first absolute position
and uh certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so conversion can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now now
I would just move to the campaign making
though we have done as I told you last
time but I will try to make it again so
that we can quickly see how the Google
ad search ads or the search Google ad
created okay so if I just go to the
campaign uh my
demo account so I have just go to the
Google ads account the dashboard and
then I would come to the
campaigns I would just click
plus new
campaign and whatever the you know um
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate uh session all
together so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
stategies we have just understood and
with uh adding the extensions to the ad
as well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is um just open
safety
learns uh landing
page so that I can make the ad for
simply andal marketing as a demo ad of
course not a main ad so copying and just
putting in here I have to just put a uh
you know website domain that's it I
don't have to bring the whole landing
page here and then I can just name it
probably November
search
add and then I would just go and
continue start
new and then I'll just select my biding
strategy which is going to be clicks and
of course from my Excel I would learn
that okay my bid price which I'm going
to be paying uh you know uh is certainly
in the range of something like probably
50 60 and I have just told you that I
bring my price kind of a thing into this
like I always bring like this and then
let me just delete all the other column
which are not
required so this is the sheet which I
did explained you earlier with the index
value and all so my price what is my
price like so I always pay 30% 40% extra
to the low bid price so I can you know
just get the formula here like
this
Plus
30% okay so that is just going to make
it 57 so you can just understand 44 + 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of X YZ factors suchar
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum paying 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I would going to
give the limit to my bid price that I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90 okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level and
then you move ahead and you remove this
because you just want to keep your ad on
the Google search and then you go down
you select your countries you select
your location if you want to show the ad
in all the locations then you certainly
can just go uh and keep the very first
option open which is uh all countries
and territories if you want to just show
your ad um uh in a particular country
like you know right now if I just go
India so the whole India would see your
ad and if you want to go for a manual
locations like suppose I want to select
any of the states or cities then what I
would do I would just probably take
Delhi so Delhi would be targeted like
this okay or probably I just want to
Target the state of Texas here so I just
would go and Target the whole state or
if I want to Target any of the provinces
of Canada so I would just go and take
the uh provinces of Ontario Canada and I
would just Target the whole Province and
now if I also wants to go for any of the
uh PIN codes suppose I want to Target to
a certain pin code then I can just go
and Target the PIN codes like this so it
is up to us that we want to go worldwide
or if you want to go for a country
specific if you want to go for a state
specific or if you want to go as a
province or a pin code specific okay
otherwise uh if you suppose um a
restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and Advan search
and then you can go into radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India we understand
kilometers better maybe the person in us
would understand miles better so we just
go and take that 2 km radius and
probably I am the cake shop in Delhi so
I was just going to search my location
this is my location and I was just going
to Target people around 2 km because I
don't deliver outside 2 km so it's all
up to us how we want to go uh this is
called radius targeting or Geo fencing
when we go to the locations we can also
learn one thing suppose I want to show
the art to the um whole country India
I've targeted but at the same time I am
not delivering in um uh in in in Mumbai
okay or probably in uh Karnataka you
know bangaluru where the city is okay
probably I'm not delivering in any of
the uh northern states like harana
Himachal Punjab so what I would do I
would just take Punjab suppose for
example and I'm just going to exclude
that okay so what would happen now my ad
would show in all the states and all the
cities of India but just not in Punjab
okay so I can save it that's how you go
about the location language is you know
in which language the users probably
uses the search engine and all so you
can keep it all languages that's the
best and audience we don't cater here
much because we are doing the search ad
which actually shows the ad on the basis
of keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the Moree settings comes where you talk
about the ad rotation so ad rotation is
uh already default being selected as the
perform best ad uh if because the
nowadays the ad actually been created uh
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you uh
the headline changes for every user the
description sometime changes for the
user what I mean is if such is selecting
or you know writing this keyword so
probably this headline is shown to me
and after 1 hour if I'll come again and
put search the same term so the headline
from the same Advertiser could be
different or the description could be
different so that's how the dynamic ADS
works like okay so once you are done
with this okay the start and dat is
important you know the basics from the
previous chapter so I'm just going
a bit faster in here so you would select
the date and then if you want to
schedule this campaign for a certain
period like suppose you don't want to
run on the weekends so you can just
select Monday to Fridays and you know
our timing whichever suits you suppose
just like a very common time of 8:00
a.m. to uh you know the late nights like
23:45 and you don't want to run the
weekends if you want um Saturday Sunday
to be you know 24 hours then you don't
have to put any timing so that go goes
like 24 hours for Saturday Sundays and
then you click next and you reach to the
next
level where it will just going to ask
you for certain things like keywords you
want to submit and the ad you want to
run for and the ad copy you know you
have to create okay so once you come
here it uh is the you know work you have
done so you can just copy paste them and
you know bring in there uh and otherwise
these all keywords are the ones which
Google has suggested you for from you
know the page which you have submitted
okay so the landing page is this so I'll
try to change the landing page first so
that I can get more appropriate keywords
and then it would going to search again
or scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show us certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
because we don't know uh what is the
pricing of these keywords is what is the
competition of these keywords is how
much the monthly search has been so we
go by our own maths we we calculate we
do all this pre homework on the Keyword
Planner sheet just like we did today and
then we bring them here by deleting all
what they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
being used how the copy is created I'll
just show
you some you know strategic part of it
ensure that your landing page is correct
and it is opening there you know
otherwise your ad would not be approved
secondly always give a display path
display path is something which is added
after the ad or the landing page link
suppose I'm selling
online digital marketing so I would just
going to write whatever I want to
show
okay probably I'll just keep it
here
marketing okay so that works okay so now
it has come raal marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to
be I'll just going to tell you the call
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which shows
you know you know the basics so I'll be
fast again under the landing page link
this blue which actually uh you know
brings the most of the engagement or
which actually appeals the user to click
it is something in blue which is you
know going to be the headline so we have
to be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
score would increase quality score would
increase your costing would come down
and your position would rise so you have
to to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and I'm just
going to get the headlines as a
suggestion being given okay and um we
can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keyword
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course
online try to get your best keywords
here this is okay this is nice this can
be
changed
digital marketing
CS online is not taking so this
Marketing Online probably I'll just take
because course are already submitted and
then I can take few more like social
media marketing I just
seen whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the
rest this is the one and I should ensure
that I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know being given
like a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have a uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so
enroll
register
today for free
demo then we'll talk
about you can see the moment I've added
the headline this the strength has
changed 100 uh
plus tools for free
three
job
assistance
program okay so I'm just adding few
random things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen uh these headlines in any of
the atank companies ads uh include some
popular keywords popular keywords could
be your brand name as well so
simply learn
courses
online hopefully the spelling is fine
and
um
weekend batch
for
professionals uhoh
[Music]
just a batch for
professionals and that's it you know
because I already added a lot of
keywords lot of headlines probably R so
I would just not work on the headlines
anymore uh and I'll see you know if
description doesn't takes it high then
I'll I'll just add one more but right
now the description is also not giving
me the full uh pick like in the headline
unique and the headlines been given so
I'll just try to bring the description
so simply online online that's great
that's great I will just try to get
something from Google itself let's see
what they have given so I'll just going
to bring this one okay so that it is
been taken from the landing page itself
so that would make a difference
to uh the quality score simp digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to
put our courses focus on
skills see to
focus
on else like seu PC
analytics just to bring this one here so
that it has been picked up so now you
can see this is also been picked up and
the last thing I would do is now going
to bring some headline again you know
I'll just check probably uh digital
marketing certification I'm not sure if
this headline I have submitted earlier
or not I'm just going to test it out
okay
so
cation
training so now it has you know come
down to good and uh that's the best you
know right now we can do of course you
can take it further but yeah that
doesn't um
uh matter if you are just stuffing it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords or all the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdue 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click
next and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we I'll just take you back so
because you know that your a CPC price
would be around 80 you know whatever the
pricing you have just got from here if
you know the sheet when I was explaining
you so the the the bid price which you
have submitted for you know when I told
you is like something which is in this
range uh 80 90 whatever it is so you
know that bit price would come down to
90 and you need um at least 100 clicks
today so 90 into 100 going to be your
9,000 daily budget so because you know
that you know you would end up in paying
maximum 90 rupees per click because
that's the maximum bid price you have
submitted if that comes down to 70 80 60
then of course your clicks would
increase but right now to being very uh
you know hypothe hypothetically thinking
that okay I would pay 90 rupees per
click at Max because that is what I
submitted so to get 100 clicks I have to
pay 90 into 100 it would be 9,000 your
you know daily budget has to be so you
would come here and you would just going
to change it set a custom budget and you
would going to bring down 9,000 rupees
here okay so on that CPC whatever it
would be you would get the number of LS
if your I CPC goes down from 90 to 45
then of course you are not going to get
only 100 you rather get double amount
which is going to be 200 okay when that
is done then you just click next and
your budget goes uh you know your
campaign goes for a
review and then you can add the
extensions from outside okay so they're
just giving you some of the uh you know
kind of uh suggestions so let's see uh
there is one issue in the ad
let me just check that
first let me just
see you can always fix
it but that would again you're not going
to give you the option of um publishing
you know till you fix it but it is not
clickable I don't
know uh what is the
problem I'll just go from here
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is I
issue one contains
and okay so we just to do that
the character limit part I have not
given the space so that is something
which is not acceptable by them just
going to put like skills like this
and now so these all small things you
know they do
to take uh care of so here only because
we have come down so why not just to see
the extension here itself because that
would uh going to save our efforts by
going from outside so when you see the
ad you see some extensions here like you
know when you have created the ad right
now so you have created only till this
limit okay this is the elements you have
put it up right now the landing page the
headline the description but in this ad
by amators you can see more links like
apply to IMS learn how industry so one
is landing page and three different uh
Pages or sub pages also been shown in
this same ad how they are done so they
are done through the extension called
site link okay so you can see here if
you go down after the headline there's
an option to have the site links here
okay so you can just click plus here
itself I'm not submitting the ad because
I wanted just to show you from here
itself and then you can go down because
in your case these would not be given
because mine are already created yours
are not so you would go down and you
would create the new new site link from
here and you can just give a name
suppose
download
brocher and then you can give a URL of
that download brocher page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page like this like
this has to be the landing page which is
workable for the downloading brocher of
course so this would be
and then I can just go and probably add
um uh
testy
monals and
reviews okay so somebody wants to read
the uh you know um testim and reviews of
when when they see the ad so you can see
that on the desktop how that would look
like so they would have an ad and then
they would have these four links and all
which you have just seen in the Google
when I shown you so final URL of reviews
can be given which which would directly
take them to the page where the reviews
been given and uh site two could be
anything you know we can just see um
industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just
know from the uh very first glimpse of
the art itself so I can just
maybe take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh uh maybe
tools
provided now tools
and
certificates you would get so that can
also be one of the links which people
would very much interested in you know
clicking and checking okay so you would
see the the ad in certain shape you
would have a normal headline uh the
description which you have put it up and
then four links where people can
directly reach okay and and then you
know this had to be saved here and you
can always see the preview which I've
already shown you but yeah this is how
that would look like so you add your add
and your four uh extra links which
actually been added okay so this is one
which you can apply
now and now your ad has the extensions
in addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your add as uh
the number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here AB right now it
is not showing any of the ads with the
number but they you know uh generally
have advertisers have nowadays the
numbers in addition to the headline and
everything okay so you can add that as
well by just going up and you can see
there is an option of calls okay okay
let me you can add from here uh
certainly I can show you but you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your country and you know
giving your number here it it'll just be
cross checked by some verification and
all so that is done you can save it so
you can see what actually I was showing
you you know I would just show you um
from outside also that if by any of the
uh you know um that is done that we have
corrected so you don't have to be you
know uh worried about so if I just click
done so that should not be there if it
is still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just U um delete the whole
description probably that would
something which and I would save our
time okay so we not adding that
description though just look done so
this is actually you know kind of a bug
because that is something which has been
deleted rather in front of you so this
this is not
um taking but I would just click next
and probably this would now be not the
error in which we would see so you go
for a review so what I was saying I did
shown you from outside the you know the
the campaign was created from the ad
itself how the S site link is connected
and how the uh call being added for now
the publish campaign you can see because
that add error actually been rectified
so if by mistake you know you just
forgotten that you have to add the call
number or extension you know which we
just added so what you don't have to be
worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaign certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the um add group and then you
can see there is ADD and assets let me
just click
that so there's an ad which you just
created and there's an assets you know
where you could see uh
the extensions and all like you know you
just have added today we just added this
site link and this number so if I want
to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if uh that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button and then you would just go
to the call and you would see the same
kind of a preview which you have seen
inside the ad when we were creating okay
nothing different it's just like the you
know way you do it you know either you
do when the ad was created or otherwise
you can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add in assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these uh extensions we'll talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough uh learning on the Google
search chart with the extensions and
also the main uh agenda for today was to
make you understand how these you know
terms works like and how the keywords
can be researched how you can bring your
own pricing to the keywords how you can
save the cost and of course to
understand how the quality score works
like you can have a lot of videos on a
YouTube where you can find the quality
score of Google ads working though I
tried to you know bring everything under
this session but still if you want to go
for a deep learning you can always
search more and research more so if you
are looking to grab a successful career
in digital marketing simply learn has
got you covered with a wide range of
topnotch digital marketing courses these
courses make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google Analytics
Keyword Planner Sam rush and there is a
huge list on the board however one year
of experience is preferred to enroll in
these course find the link to the course
in the description box what social media
marketing actually means what is it yeah
and we got to put this in the context of
the definition of
marketing yeah I studied Marketing in
the very early days in the 80s and um my
main sort of uh Guru in marketing was
Philip Cotler and over the years
marketing has sort of developed from
traditional marketing to online
marketing but the basic concept has not
changed if you look at the definition of
marketing it's the activity of creating
communicating delivering and exchanging
offerings that have value for
customers yeah so you supply you deliver
you exchange products or services that
have a value for your
customers so two very important aspects
here there is value and there is
customer and that is what we capture in
the marketing concept you put the
customer at the core of what you do
yeah because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the
customer yep so take social media
marketing in that context then the
second part of the social media
marketing sort of term is the word
social media what is social media when I
explain social media I'm using the three
C's the three C's of social media
marketing and they are content they
community and
campaigns content is the fuel of your
social media content is the um the
currency of social media if you have
really good content that you can share
on the
internet yeah using various multip
multiple social media channels like
Facebook like YouTube or like video or
like Instagram or blogging you name it
yeah people will engage with your
content and then when people start
engaging with your content they may come
back for more content that you supply
and they will then become part of your
community so Community is a very
important aspect of your social media
def definition with really good content
you can create
communities and then you can push that
process by running
campaigns yeah and a campaign makes it
relevant for
businesses because when you run a
campaign you have a goal for your
campaign you have an objective you have
a St date you have an end
date yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting
content and then you put it into the
marketing context you do that with a
customer at in the core of what you
do yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media
marketing is very basic it says the use
of social media to develop a company's
brand
increase website traffic and boost
sales that is what we call social media
marketing yeah the most important aspect
here is that you need to have an outcome
you need to have a result which is
customer
related and that is where the sales
element comes in you do this to get get
the customer to do something and in the
end that is buying your product or your
service yeah so social media marketing
is not the
Tactical combination of your social
media networks yeah to um to reach as
many people there needs to be a goal to
it and when we talk about marketing it
comes down to selling your product or
service with a
value yes so that is the um kind of the
call to action as it were that comes out
of your social media marketing so keep
that in mind everything you do with your
social media marketing in the end comes
down to reaching your goals or achieving
your objectives of developing your
company's brand increasing website
traffic or growing your
sales now a big benefit that you're
getting these days in digital marketing
and social media marketing is
data is
intelligence is
knowledge in the early days of marketing
the biggest problem has always been how
to measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and uh they write about
me in a newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I Ran So in the early pre-
interet days yeah we the only way to
measure customer engagement as it were
were through loyalty card or credit
cards yeah with a loyalty card you had
some basic customer data through credit
cards you could track
transactions but it's very difficult to
relate that to your marketing then the
internet emerged and all of a sudden I
could track traffic to my
website yeah I could see how many people
visit my website are these people that
visit my website for the first time are
they returning visitors what are the
most popular p pages that they see how
long do they stay on my website and are
they actually buying my
product yeah so that was a major
advancement of marketing in the early
2000s and then when social media emerged
it all of a sudden became possible to
measure
engagement how many people are having
conversations with us I could even
measure sentiments our people positive
about my brand are they negative about
my Brands I could track the
effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns I could measure the
effectiveness of my advertising
campaigns that I ran online so today's
reality is that we can measure
everything we can measure clicks we can
measure transactions we can measure
engagements we can measure return on
investments yeah and we can now even
take that a step further further through
artificial intelligence that we can
actually start making predictions how
people may respond to campaigns that
we're going to be running so it's a very
important aspect of your digital uh your
social media marketing now let's go into
the social media marketing tips and
tricks number one set up your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make and this is exactly why
setting up goals is very important
moreover your marketing efforts have to
align with the goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a thousand conversions by
the end of the quarter or 5,000
followers on Instagram by the end of the
month and so on number two you need to
stick to a consistent deadline this
gives weight for each of your options
and number three make sure your goals
are smart now smart refers to specific
measurable attainable relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy
and alongside these goals there also
needs to be the Northstar metric now
what is the Northstar metric well this
represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular northstars there's increased
engagement greater conversion rates more
leads generated app downloads and and so
on now let's go to number two
understanding your
audience social media allows you to
interact engage and build relationships
with your Audience by understanding what
they need want and desire you can
deliver content in a way that makes your
product or service the answer that
they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in forums responding to their comments
and blogs and social media taking up
their feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learn's audience is predominantly
working Professionals in graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
BYU app has high school students as
users now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform now when performing social
media marketing choosing the right
platform is really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there's the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest now let's talk about the
purpose of each of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences for
Facebook well just about everyone has an
account on
it content that is related to news or
entertainment usually find success on
Facebook and then we have Instagram
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form video It Doesn't
Really drive a lot of traffic to your
website it and then finally we have
Pinterest Pinterest is also limited to
static images however it's highly
effective at driving traffic to your
blog now let's go to number four setting
up a social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen posts like tag a friend who
does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media then
we have polls and surveys polls can help
you if you need a collection that also
encourages followers to take action and
interact polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brand and by extension helps increase
customer loyalty and Trust And Then
There are is infographics articles and
images so social media calendars are
successful because of their ability to
increase collaboration within the team
help understand what works and what
doesn't and in distributing resources in
an effective
manner next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools social media marketing tools align
to the goals of your organization with
it you can create highquality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar now some of the more popular
social media tools include buffer hoot
site Buzz Sumo if T and much more now
these tools also help with generating
leads creating email lists finding a
relevant audience to show your content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of
posts now for number six visual
storytelling visual storytelling
involves passing out a lot of
information in the simplest of forms
visually using pictures and videos your
followers are able to grasp the message
quickly and remember it for a long time
afterwards visual storytelling is also
not limited by language barriers and
this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much
more but it also has some other
advantages it helps you build a bond
with your audience visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly Gras the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential
customers so have a look at some of our
videos so here's what is machine
learning data science in 5 minutes and
AI in 5 minutes now these are some of
our most viewed videos on our Channel
and now you know why visual storytelling
if you guys are interested in watching
these videos you can check them out on
our Channel homepage and we also have
similar videos on blockchain devops and
Six Sigma but now back to the
list let's go to number seven paying for
advertising
this is a method that helps you find a
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing
goal and this can help you improve your
reach and improve your Brand's
visibility it's payperclick model and
shows cost Effectiveness by providing
great results and return on investment
it also helps improve targeting by
letting you control who sees your ad you
get to choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types alongside the basic
user demographics like age location
gender and so on now since most social
media platforms have native analytics
you also get to assess and Define the
performance of your ad
campaigns now as great as it sounds
there are certain pitfalls that come
along with peer advert iing first of all
your audience could get exposed to your
post too many times and tune out your
content disregarding it in the
process second it could get really
expensive for small businesses or
startups to manage a campaign to its
maximum Effectiveness third people could
pass off your content as irrelevant or
unimportant and you also have to deal
with a lot of
competition smaller companies with less
ER budgets have more of an uphill battle
to deal with than better funded
organizations next we have number eight
newsjacking newsjacking is a method that
involves using current events to promote
your own Brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness newsjacking uses
the popularity of current events and
drives it to your brand it helps shine a
spotlight on your product
and it also helps you show off that you
are up to- dat with current events in
the industry and that your product is
relevant by extension it also improves
engagement and website
traffic now for number nine AB
testing AB testing is a popular method
for comparing copies creatives and ctas
or call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media
now since audiences would react
differently depending on the content AB
testing helps determine which of the
variants your audience engaged with the
most AB testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on and next up number 10 community and
influences joining communities helps
your brand link up with like-minded
people and other companies belonging to
your Niche it'll also help you establish
your brand as an authority within the
industry actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up
with and on the other hand partnering up
with influencers helps promote your
products or services to a brand new
audience it helps provide an additional
layer of authenticity in YouTube which
is also a social media platform if you
didn't know here are some very very
popular influencers we have Marcus
brownley unbox therapy Mr who's the boss
and lonus Tech tips each of them with
more than 4 million
subscribers and finally we're at number
11 measuring and analyzing
results accurately tracking and
measuring your marketing efforts are an
important part of the process it ensures
that you're making the most out of your
campaigns now it's really important that
you find key metrics that are crucial
for your brand and these metrics can be
tracked weekly monthly or on a quarterly
basis and based on these results
appropriate actions can be
taken so on Facebook you could look out
for reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for Impressions clicks
and Impressions and interactions on
LinkedIn and likes comments and mentions
on Instagram and engagements and
Impressions on
Pinterest some of the most popular tools
used for this purpose are Sprout social
buffer hoot Suite Google analytics and
so on is literally content marketing um
okay what is it so content marketing Is
Not A New Concept it's been around for
over a 100 years in fact one of the
classic found stories of you know the
birth of content marketing goes all the
way back to the Michelin Brothers in
France and the Michelin Brothers you
know in case you haven't done your
history that's okay you know little
refresher right now were two brothers
who made pneumatic tires and they were
trying to sell them along with an
Innovative product at its time called
the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know rep Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to dive for the Ratatouille H you
you got to have it this is a three star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a new IC and you know what
it's it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content but got the audience to get into
their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Mich solds more tires so that that's
a great story every time you sort of you
know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing we need to come
up with a concept think back to the
Michelin guide it's it's a great
foundation so let's go to a modern
definition where are we now in the 21st
century when it comes to content
marketing well you can read the slide
here and read the definition and some
people like reading definitions I'm not
going to read it to you but I am going
to highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any
definition of content
marketing the content that you create
needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not actually meeting my needs or
interests you know and why would I be
interested in them and we've gotten way
too tired of screening out the
commercial that comes on um you know
trying to sell us snow tires and pardon
me we live in Florida I don't use snow
tires what the what the heck is this
commercial doing you know interrupting
what I'm
watching so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out and the
valuable the valuable can can work in a
lot of different ways it can be
interesting it can be useful you know
value is an interesting proposition all
by
itself but that's the key to content
marketing uh it's not just creating more
spam it's not just throwing more trash
over the fence and hoping something
happens this is something where if
you've created valuable and relevant
content you know what your customers
will find you it's a whole different
kind of
proposition I know there's some Skeptics
who saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module
three but let me just be clear
here social media content is part of
what content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that U your
PR people can share with uh uh reporters
or blogers and that's not normally
considered uh social media content and
by the way all of that content can be
optimized so maybe it actually is part
of SEO not social media marketing in
fact that's the other place that content
marketing really
overlaps and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update all of a sudden even seos started
to pay attention to content marketing
why because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant you
know what it's not going to rank very
well in our search algorithm
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places realized content matters
you mean I've got to actually tell
stories that are interesting I've got to
create information that's
valuable yeah yeah you can make it
relevant that's the optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash God bless you good
luck so yeah content marketing has grown
it's like tripled in terms of web search
interest since the panda update and
we're talking about Panda 1 of course
there was Panda 2 Panda 3 Panda 4 I mean
come on Google is driving us in this
direction and so content marketing is
pretty relevant
today now one of the other things that
uh people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand I do
B2B content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a
second you know content marketing has
been around now long enough and enough
people have done it but some research
has been conducted and it's been
conducted against B Toc marketers and
B2B marketers and small business
marketers and Enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like okay we're going to try
to determine what is the difference
between an effective content marketer
and an ineffective content
marketer let's see the results well
first of all the most important thing to
Be an Effective betc content
marketer is you need a documented
content strategy
oh okay all right mean people who are
winging it aren't as uh effective as
people who actually have thought about
this written it down got it okay no
great Insight but you know interesting
to note secondly they got to have
somebody in charge who oversees content
marketing oh Lord does that mean we have
to have a reorg or maybe we just have to
designate somebody who reports to
somebody else whatever but guess what
it really helps if somebody is driving
this
process third they've got to be using
more content marketing tactics than
their less effective
peers and this is not an argument more
is better this is just pardon me that's
the way the data falls out the people
who are actually more effective are
doing more different kinds of
things a broader range of
tactics and who knows maybe it's that
broader range that's part of the success
formula same thing is true with social
media
platforms the effective content
marketers are using more than the
ineffective ones and last but not least
and this may be a sort of a result of
the first four by gosh effective content
marketers generally have greater
percentage of the overall marketing
budget in their organization
wow okay that's the b2c marketing form
but you don't understand I'm not a BTC
marketer yeah yeah okay so let's take a
look at the B2B content marketing
formula guess what you need to have a
documented content marketing strategy to
Be an Effective B2B content marketer you
need to have someone who oversees
content marketing strategy it helps if
you are using more tactics and more
social media platforms and guess what
you spend a higher percentage of your
overall marketing Budget on content
marketing well that's similar to the b2c
content marketers but do you understand
B2B is different yeah there's a couple
small differences but guess what overall
the top five criteria are similar and
when you get to small business here's
what you're going to see same five
criteria and you're in an Enterprise I
know the world is different for
Enterprises actually not so much so four
different data points let's net it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
I don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are you can be B Toc B2B
you can be small business you can be
large Enterprise at the end of the day
there are five things that you've got to
focus on if you want to be
effective we've already cover these and
are there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and B Toc well
sure but they're all at the
margin what's the downside if we don't
do this you know as anyone going to come
in and like wack us and the answer is um
maybe not inside your boardroom but it
may happen on the next sales call that
one of your salespeople makes they may
encounter someone I like to call the man
in the chair and the Man in the chair
actually refers back to a classic McGraw
Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks theoretically some questions from
quote maybe your salesperson okay I
don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your company's you know
reputation or anything about and so what
was it you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not having a
Content marketing
program content marketing has been
around for over a 100 years but in the
online World customers are behaving in
lots of new ways and they're consuming
content on various kinds and types of
devices that changes things content
marketing is now about creating content
that consumers will engage with and act
upon not just read or listen to or watch
so in this introductory module we're
going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decisionmaking process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions can actually
uh happen faster you can basically uh
shorten the decision making process and
you can reach and expand um to new
prospects so one of the things that we
hope that you're going to uh learn after
uh basically taking this module uh you
should be able to do the following first
of all you can Define content marketing
and other related Concepts secondly you
should be able to explain why content
needs to be relevant and valuable in
order for it to be effective third you
need to describe uh the overlap between
content marketing SEO social media
marketing fourth you need to name five
traits of effective content
marketers and last but not least you
need to explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning
outcomes so content marketing Is Not A
New Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know little refresher
right now were two brothers who made
pneumatic tires and they were trying to
sell them along with an Innovative
product at its time called the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know we're Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther and use them so what did
they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came came up with the one
two and three star rating system to say
this restaurant I know it's way out
there it's you know bad roads uh but
guess what to dive for the Ratatouille H
you you got to have it this is a three
star restaurant you you it's worth
making the trip and oh by the way since
we're going to give you a guide and you
have to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way uh which
hotels uh you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content that got the audience to get
into their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of what is email marketing well email
has been around for a very long time of
course and in the very early days there
wasn't an email marketing service that
you could use yeah you couldn't easily
send out hundreds of emails so what you
did you were actually using the BCC or
the blind carbon copy in your email
system to send out emails to many people
of course the IT department of companies
in those early days they didn't like
that because it would block the email
system of the company so they come up
with little marketing uh email Marketing
Solutions on the company's main frame
but it was all very inflexible you had
to take your email you had to take your
mailing list give that to the guy in the
IT department and if you're lucky then
maybe in a couple of days later your
email would be sent you wouldn't get any
data at all about those emails yeah you
knew how many emails were sent but you
didn't know who would have opened the
email or who would have clicked on the
email nowadays of course things are
completely different yeah now you have
email marke where you can use email
service providers who offer you lots of
tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns so what actually is
email marketing it uses email addresses
from people to inform your email list
about your product or service we call
these commercial emails which is
completely different of course from from
the billions of personal emails that are
being sent yeah around the uh the
internet every day so this is a
commercial email that you send to an
email list about your product your
service or a newsletter and what have
you Additionally you can integrate it
into your marketing automation so you
can and it can help your customers to
see your latest products and offers and
you can obviously use the email list to
and persuade them to buy or book a demo
or sign up for a trial or register for
an event yeah we call this email
nurturing where you can send a range of
emails to take people through that
journey to help them to make the
decision so what are the different uses
of email marketing it can be used in
relationship building with existing
customers who bought a product for
instance send them a thank you email it
could be to boost brand awareness it
could be about promoting various pieces
of content it can help you in generating
leads or to promote or Market your
products and very important you can use
it to nurture leads welcome everyone
this is Rob Sanders from Simply learn
and today we're going to talk about
affiliate marketing so let's jump right
into it and take a look inside an office
environment right now we have Chuck here
Chuck St a little bit of pacing John
walks in the office hey man what's with
all the pacing everything all right
Chuck responded hey I'm just worri that
I might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done Page search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I got to come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution a affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
John's just taken over now and he's
going to let Chuck know everything there
is to know about affiliate marketing so
the first question John answers for
Chuck what is affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is a form of digital
marketing that involves a merchant it
involves a merchant paying commissions
to a website or other entities so if I'm
selling a product basically somebody
else sells that product for me I'm going
to pay that person a commission for
selling my product it's that simple
that's what affiliate marketing is okay
so basically what these Merchants are
doing or other enties they're
advertising your product so they're
advertising your product with a referral
so they're passing on their own
customers to you so that they can buy
your product and again The Exchange is
you give that website or other entity a
commission that's more or less what
affiliate marketing is so John's going
to have us take a look at each of these
components of affiliate marketing in
detail take it away John so John says
first we have the merchant AKA The Brand
the seller the Creator the founder the
owner the inspiration the innovator hey
this is the person who came up with this
brilliant idea idea This brilliant idea
has to get out there we're the merchant
we're trying to get this brilliant idea
out to the masses so this is the
component of affiliate marketing that
creates the product the merchant could
be anyone okay so it could be startups
to large multinational companies
International companies nonprofits
for-profits individuals independent
contractors Freelancers a group of
people who have a passion for something
okay it could be anybody there's no
limit the affiliate aka the publisher so
the affiliate is basically that
third-party website or entity which
promotes the Merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchants products value so this
affiliate going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular Merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if I'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey I can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if I'm got this big you know
offline you know promotion that I'm
doing at this particular mall and I want
to get people there well I can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always
always have to be sales per se so in
effect you the merchant and the
affiliate work out some type of
commission deal based on what you're
incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your perspective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a mer
mer you want to be able to manage your
Affiliates so you're not going to have
one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in that affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers digital marketing
tools are essential Assets in the modern
marketing landscape these software
Solutions and platforms Empower
businesses and marketers to plan execute
analyze and optimize their online
marketing strategies from search engine
optimization and social media management
to email marketing analytics and content
creation these tools streamline
processes enhance efficiency and drive
better results in the digital realm in
this digital age leveraging the right
marketing tools is the key to staying
competitive and achieving marketing
objectives effectively so if you are
looking to become a digital marketing
specialist and learn all the essential
digital marke marting tools then look no
further than simply learns post-graduate
program in digital marketing with this
you will gain all the necessary skills
in digital marketing like website
creation behavioral marketing keyword
research search engine optimization
search engine marketing campaign
management social media marketing and
more so if you are looking to become a
digital marketing specialist and learn
all the essential digital marketing
tools then look no further then simply
learns postgraduate program progr in
digital marketing with this you gain all
the necessary skills in digital
marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like a ranking hoods suit chat
JP Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there's much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity as only one year
of experience is preferred to enroll in
this course take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerate your career
and gain the skills you need to thrive
in the industry ready to get started
click the link in the description box
and embark on your journey to
professional growth and achievement
without any further Ado let's begin the
number one tool in our list is Google
analytics website tracking plays an
important role in digital marketing it
helps in understanding the user behavior
on your website do you know that there
are around 38 million websites that use
Google analytics including Airbnb Uber
Spotify and udmi analytics is an
analytics tools used for tracking a
website the standard version of Google
analytics is free we can integrate
Google analytics with Google ads as well
the key features of Google analytics
include tracking website traffic user
demographics page views bounce rates
conversion rate rates and much more with
these valuable insights businesses can
optimize their digital strategies
improve user experience and ultimately
boost online performance towards the
next tool which is Google ads Google ads
is a vital tool in digital marketing it
lets businesses display the ads on
Google search results and partner sites
key features include keyword targeting
budget control audience targeting and Dr
analytics advertisers can optimize ads
for mobile conduct AB testing and
benefit from the features like
remarketing and AD extensions it's a
versatile tool for reaching the Right
audience at the right time driving
traffic and boosting conversions in the
competitive online landscape on number
three we have Google search console
Google search console is a free web
master tool provided by Google it is
important to timely monitor your website
and make it error free this is where
Google search console comes into the
picture it helps businesses to Monitor
and maintain their websites present in
Google search result some features of
Google Search console includes getting
confirmation that the Google search
engine can crawl your website fix the
problems in the page indexing sense page
for reindexing can view Google search
traffic data record the number of times
your website appears in the search
results records the search engine
queries for which your websites appears
in the search results show the list of
sites linking to you and many more on
number four we have Sam rush to grow
your business it is essential to keep an
eye on what your competitors are doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and Implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitor
analysis srash is a competitor analysis
tools that gives a complete work through
of the competitors's data like keywords
backlinks top performing content
campaigns Etc it has free as well as
paid versions on number five we have
MailChimp MailChimp is a popular email
marketing platform known for its
userfriendly interface it offers
features like email campaign creation
marketing automation audience
segmentation analytics and integration
with other tools it's widely used for
engaging with audiences and nurturing
leads through the personalized email
marketing on number six we have C Cana
canva is a userfriendly graphic design
tool that empowers digital marketers to
create eye-catching visuals for social
media email marketing ads infographics
and more it helps to maintain Brad
consistency enhance content engagement
and simplifies the design process making
it a valuable asset in digital marketing
efforts next we have is HubSpot hubs
sport is all-in-one digital marketing
and sales platform known for its inbound
marketing strategies it provides tools
for Content creation automation CRM
analytics and more hubs sport helps
businesses attract engage hubs sport
helps businesses to attract engage and
convert leads into customers by
streamlining marketing and sales efforts
on number eight we have ah revs gaining
high quality backlink is an essential
factor in digital marketing and SEO
ranking as it shows the trust of other
website in your content moreover it
helps in building the authority of your
website ahrs is a comprehensive SE
toolkit that includes features like
backlink analysis keyword research site
Audits and competitor analysis it's
valuable tool for improving website
performance and achieving better search
engine rankings the next tool on the
list we have is grammarly grammarly is a
vital tool in digital marketing ensuring
error free engaging content across the
channel it enhances quality SE
optimization and consistency time saving
and improving audience engagement in
email social media and content creation
last but not least we have moss moss is
a key player in digital marketing
specializing in SEO tools and resources
it helps marketers with keyword research
backlink analysis onpage SEO local SEO
content strategies and Technical SEO
most also offers educational content and
supportive Community to stay updated
with SEO best practices and Industry
Trends so if you are looking to grab a
successful career in digital marketing
simply learn has got you covered with
the wide range of topnotch digital
marketing courses these courses make you
skilled in SEO content marketing PPC
social media marketing and much more
with hands-on experience in the tools
like Google Analytics
Keyword Planner Sam rush and there's a
huge list on the board however one year
of experience is preferred to enroll in
these course find the link to the course
in the description box greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders with simply
learn thank you for joining and today
we're going to cover digital marketing
interview questions and answers so
thanks for joining again and here's how
it's going to work so we broke out a few
questions and answers uh in different
categories a lot of you are going to be
interviewing for some jobs out there and
some of the jobs maybe an SEO manager or
or search engine marketing manager or
email marketing manager or content
marketing manager or social media
manager so we broke up those questions
into those areas and so that's what
we're going to do we're going to start
with sea we're going to go through some
questions and I'm going to explain the
answers to those questions so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
as soon as possible so let's get started
we're going to start with SEO search
engine optimization we're going to go
through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you Tak in listen to
my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we we
talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site B we're
going to basically tell Google Bing and
some of these other search engines hey
go ahead and follow that link now I know
follows just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site s site a pointing to
site B we can put a no follow tag in
there and what that's going to do it's
going to signal to the Crawlers hey
don't follow this link so in the end if
the Crawlers don't follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
passed and so Google is not going to
give you credit or give that site credit
for having a link pointing to it or
pointing to another site or from another
site and and so it's all about linking
so we can control if there's links on
our site whether we want the Crawlers to
recognize those or not simply with no
follow Texs so just a reminder link use
is the reputation or Equity passed from
one website to another so if you have a
link on another website and that website
is of high quality meaning their page
Authority their domain Authority is high
they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant they then you may
want to make sure that the link pointing
from that site to your site is a no
follow so that way that Google can
recognize the link from that site to
your site and basically that reputation
is going to be passed on to you okay so
that's a do follow versus a no follow
and why would we do a no follow well it
depends it really depends a lot of
social media platforms like Facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do followers it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice on to and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an SEO perspective if I have a site
and I have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites I'm
going to be particular about who I allow
the search engine to follow and what
links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the hre
notice the no follow has the the tag
appended to it the hre tag with a no
follow so if the search engines crawling
your site and they see that no follow
there they're not going to follow that
link and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
are I'm going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyw here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we don't have a
page anymore we have a new page let's
just say you built a new website with
new URLs you want to make sure the old
page is pointing to the new page with a
301 redirect so if a 301 redirect is
permanent then a 302 is temporary so we
want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might alert Google to not keep
that page in its search engine rankings
because it's temporary so why would
Google want to keep a temporary page or
even a page that is pointing to another
page on a temporary basis so they REM
May remove both pages from its index
okay but if we have something permanent
in place Google may say okay this page
is permanently linking to another page
or redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary may not be as stable in the
eyes of say Google
and if they don't see it as stable then
they may remove both pages from the
index okay so the ideas we want to be
found in Google search index and we get
it sometimes Pages go away for a variety
of reasons and if it does go away just
make sure you have a new page for it and
that new page is a 301 permanent
redirect okay so question three why are
backlinks important in SEO well we kind
of hinted on that a bit with the no
follow because if we have a link from
another website pointing to ours and
that link from that other website is
really relevant and and it has a high
page and domain Authority then it's
going to benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from high quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a lineon share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an onpage
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
D domain Authority Google sees us is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having back links is important
because it snowballs all the way through
to conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for a web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty I.E low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter or Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then let's go about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
going to like it and then other people
are going to see that engagement they're
going to see how many people liked it or
how many subscribers you have so promote
your videos to help you with the ranking
of the video on YouTube so that does
play into it so go ahead and promote it
so other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so if that smartphone
bot goes to your website and starts
crawling what do you think they're
looking for their smartphone bot they're
looking for mobile friendly content if
it's not mobile friendly meaning the
page isn't designed for a a smartphone
browser or let's just say the images are
way too large or you have to expand the
text just to read it you know a lot of
these these issues that somebody would
have just simply trying to read
something on a web page on their mobile
device Google's not going to grab that
content so you want to make sure it's
mobile friendly so it gets indexed and
so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked you this question you could even
take it a step further and say look I'm
going to measure how friendly my my
website is for mobile devices in Google
search console because Google search
console has a report that will show you
what pages on your website are not
mobile friendly and it's not a guarantee
but I could tell if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bot and that pay page or one of my pages
is not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who ask you this question because how
you going to know if one of your pages
is mobile friendly or not if you don't
look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mo mobile
usability report okay number six list
down the most important local SEO
ranking factors okay so organic local
ranking is just as important as anything
else in organic search because if you
have a local business you want to use
the likes of say Google my business to
show up when somebody types in you know
looking for a florist or you looking for
a coffee shop so what you want to do is
you want to create a web page for every
product and service okay you also want
to opt for your business listings on
Google my business and and there are
plenty of other local business
directories out there like Yelp for
example or Bing even has one so go ahead
and also make sure you have a business
listing as well but since Google in the
United States has a huge market share
you want to start with Google first you
want to update your nap citations on
your website maintain consistency of
your nap okay so nap is name name
address phone number so you want to make
sure that that's current and consistent
so if you have a number on your website
make sure it's a same number on Google
my business okay you can embed a Google
map on your website you could certainly
optimize the metatags and content not
only on your web pages but within your
Google my business directory so you can
add your business to other local
directories like I mentioned Yelp and
then also just as important op for
reviews and ratings okay so the more
reviews that H you have the better off
you are okay so I always say this with
or with local search three of the main
factors in showing up for local search
on say Google is obviously the keyword
the second is the proximity of where
that person is and then third is the
reviews so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages and your website but
also you can translate that over to
Google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure you're your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directories that's really all
these are really key factors for local
SEO okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember 301s
are permanent we can also use what they
call canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is op for
preferred domain in Google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three I would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page is going to alert
Google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you can
just tell the search engines hey this is
the original page or you can go through
search console okay number eight what
are the tactics to increase a web page
speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible what I mean by
simple as possible really I mean hey use
a simple website design don't get overly
creative if you will most websites all
websites have images you're not going to
be able to get around that but just make
sure you optimize your images in other
words don't have such a large image size
if you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time and what do we mean
by that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have a an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for SEO okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optim minifying when
we see minifying we mean get rid of some
of the Redundant code if you have CSS
you know get rid of chop some of the get
rid of the JavaScript you're not using
so that's what we mean by optimizing
code reduce redirects okay ideally you
just want to have one redirect in place
you don't want to create a daisy chain
so to speak of redirecting and
redirecting after that that's never
going to bode well and it's going to
slow things down as well enable browser
caching so if you enable browser caching
basically somebody comes back to the
page they've been on say two days ago
they're probably going to see a cach
version of that page and then opt for
the content delivery Network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to Google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speit insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the UR URL Google is going to analyze
the URL for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see Google gives a
score so we could see the score for
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here I could see some of the issues
that the site may be having in terms of
page low time for their desktop if I
flip over to mobile you know here I can
see some other issues for example they
have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here and or you can just
always Google it as well uh here you got
the reduce the impact of third party
code okay so that's another thing uh
reduce Java Script execution time so
again going back to a lot of some of the
comments we met about coding okay some
sometimes too much code or code not
functioning as well as it should we'll
tend to slow down the site okay so you
can use page spe insights you can always
get a glimpse of how pages are loading
simply by also going to for example
Google analytics under Behavior okay you
can go to site speed and if you click on
overview okay Google what Google does is
they do a sampling of pages over time
and in this case based on 89 Page views
they have an average page load time and
so you can get a sense of how quick
specific page is load to your site
overall simply by looking at the site
speed overview report in Google
analytics to get a sense of how quick
your pages are loading now there's
certain factors that do affect load time
so obviously the way the page is built
with the code the images Etc but also
the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the United States and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know co uh Ivory Coast in Africa
okay so it really depends on the network
you're on so and also the page every
page is built differently so you want to
get a sense of what pages are loading
quicker and which pages are not you can
simply just go to page timings in Google
analytics and you get a sense of what
pages do not load fast which ones do and
maybe hone in on the pages that aren't
loading fast and address those pages
first okay so you have two tools at your
disposal one Google analytics and one
page speed insights okay so let's look
at question number nine here so when
should an individual Target short tail
and long tail keywords okay so remember
short tail are usually one to two
keywords very Broad in nature long tail
keywords maybe three four keywords in a
query or maybe an entire sentence those
are considered longtail keywords so
usually short tail keywords have higher
volume but also higher competition
longer tail keywords usually have lower
uh volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about longtail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague Oro in nature longtail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but if
somebody types in exactly that product
name you show up the chance of you them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific of the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say longtail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody ask me this question
in an interview what am I going to focus
on while developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mob ball is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone B so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat easy for somebody
to find the the rule of Thum is if it's
good for the end user probably going to
be good for Google but if complicated
for the end User it's probably going to
be complicated for Google you always
want to create a sitemap now what is
that sitemap a Sit map is simply just a
formatted file with to that's includes
all your URLs and assets your images and
your videos they're going to be sitting
on your server as well so you want
Google or these these Bots to be able to
find your pages and assets and by by the
way you want to take it a step further
and make sure you upload that site map
which is sitting in the root directory
meaning
domain.com sitemap.xml okay you want to
take that sitap and make sure you input
that sitap location in Google search
console that way Google search console
has a oneway ticket to grab the elements
in the sitemap another important element
to focus on while developing a WIP site
is having a robot's text file and all a
robots text file is it's like a lock I
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's going to be
able to get in that door so it's all a
robots text file is you're telling
Google and these other Bots that are
coming ACR your site what's locked and
what's not locked meaning what they have
access to what they don't have access to
so you want to be able to make sure you
have a robot's text file if you're
trying to non index specific pages of
your website because if you tell Google
don't craw these Pages or this directory
they're not going to get crawled if they
don't get crawled they're not going to
get indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website I'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it in it
so there are a lot of reasons to have
robots text files that's the main reason
sitap you want Google to get these pages
and assets quickly okay you want to make
sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when I say content I don't necessarily
just mean words I also mean videos I
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if if an end user finds your side
engaging Google is likely going to find
your side engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just a recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so that Bots can easily access
and mix content okay with a responsive
design helps to make your It Mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
Bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robots text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house so here we wrap up
digital marketing course if you have any
queries regarding any Concept in the
video feel free to add it in the comment
section and our experts will be happy to
help you do subscribe to Simply learn to
stay updated with new technology Trends
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here